weeks we will know whether that
continues to be uh
flat or whether it rises a little it has
risen a little in scotland i just will
put that warning in there but that is
precisely the sort of data we'll be
looking at at the two week point
in terms of vaccinations we have been
absolutely clear
that the goal on which we hang the
decision
ahead of the 19th of july is
one on delivering the vaccines and we
have a very high degree of confidence
that we can deliver the vaccines that we
think are needed
in order then to be able to take step
four on
the 19th of july i hope that's a clear
and comprehensive
uh question what's what i untangled
myself
from my uh my initial response this
question and i'll get our giveaway on
front bench i'm extremely grateful to
him
isn't the problem though with this
two-week checkpoint that it creates
another moment of hope for people who
still feel the even these restrictions
very acutely
and isn't there the problem if you
create hope and then shift the goal
posts again
people continue to deepen their despair
what would you say to them
because i think people understand that
we are putting forward
the moments by which we can make
assessments and then we'll make
assessments according to the data we've
done that
uh throughout and i think people get
that i think people got
understood that ahead of the 21st of uh
of june
and i think people are smart enough uh
to understand
that distinction madam uh mr deputy
speaker and after this
four-week pause we will be in a stronger
position because of this vaccination
rollout we've been discussing
to keep hospitalizations down and so to
live with this disease and take that
final step
on the road map the regulations turning
to the regulations themselves
um they would put this pause into effect
by amending the expiry date of the
regulations
so they expire at midnight on the
evening of the 18th
of july to reflect this change we also
need to align the dates on several other
covet regulations which are essential
for keeping us safe these include the
regulations for face coverings on public
transport
for the regulations that give powers to
manage local outbreaks
by canceling events and closing
individual premises
and the regulations that give local
authorities powers to enforce covert
secure measures for businesses
and these will all be extended until
midnight on the 18th
of july mr deputy speaker we don't want
to extend
these regulations a day longer than we
have to and we've always said that we'd
ease restrictions as soon as we were
able safely to do
and even though we've put forward these
regulations to pause step four we're
also
putting forward regulations to ease
restrictions in some areas too
these regulations will allow us to
remove the 30-person gathering limit for
weddings receptions and commemorative
events
subject of course to social distancing
measures and they'll allow us to run
another phase of our pilots for large
events
at higher capacities including some like
wimbledon
at full capacity the wimbledon finals
even though we haven't been able to take
the full step forward
as we wanted the regulations would allow
us to make some
cautious changes that will bring some
joy to many people
and move us slightly further down the
road to recovery
i will i thank normal friends for giving
away and on important life events while
it is
we welcomed some of the slight relaxing
on things like weddings there's certain
other key life events
that have not been included and i'm
looking at likes of bar mitzvahs and
baptisms which means so much of so many
will my honourable friend look at that
restrictions again or even look at the
two-week cutter point
uh two-week in the future point to see
can those life events like baptisms
be subject to reducing regulations well
i am happy to look at other life events
not for these regulations which are uh
before the house
uh today and they are a um they're not
open to amendment
um i would um but i am happy to
discuss with my honourable friend and
look at other uh life
events uh mr deputy speaker if i can
turn to two other points before
uh closing um the um first the motion
table by my right-hand
friend the leader of the house this
house has been
determined to ensure that even in the
worst clutches of the pandemic
we've found a way to ensure democracy
can function
and this house perform its vital
functions
like everyone here i miss the bustle
and the clamour of the chamber when it's
full and i can't wait for the moment
when we can all cram once more into our
cockpit of
democracy and just as we've extended
other
regulations we propose extending the
hybrid arrangements for this house
until the house rises for summer recess
on the 22nd of july
and this will allow for yes in a moment
for proxy voting to continue
along with virtual participation but
crucially
they fall this summer recess so when we
return
in september we're confident that we can
return in full
cheat by jowl once more and i don't know
about you mr speaker or indeed my own
friend but i can't wait
mr speaker i want to help my honorable
friend he can't wait so why wait
why not make this house a pilot to see
what happens
we've got the testing facilities let's
make it a pilot
say that now secretary of state well i
would i i would
i would dearly uh love that and i will
go and talk to my
uh right on friend the leader of the
house who i understand as an enthusiast
uh also uh and uh well i know that very
well um
and um and i i would love it uh if we
could make
that so um let us see i finally also
want to
um tell the house about the results of
our consultation on vaccination as a
condition of deployment
in care homes after careful consultation
we've decided to take this proposal
forward
to protect residents now the vast
majority of staff in care homes are
already vaccinated
but not all and we know that the vaccine
not only protects you but protects
those around you and therefore we will
be taking forward
the measures to ensure the mandation
for as a condition of deployment for
staff
in care homes and we will consult
on the same approach in the nhs in order
to save lives and protect patients
from disease in our giveaway we
then explain to the house whether or not
visitors to care homes or hospitals
will also require proof of vaccination
will delivery drivers
will people who provide other services
to those care homes and hospitals
require the same
and is he not now walking down the road
of requiring
mandatory vaccination for almost
everyone
no we i i do not agree with mandatory
vaccination
of the public but for those who have a
duty to care
in an environment that includes some of
the most vulnerable people in the
country
i think that this is a sensible and
reasonable step in order to
save lives mrs
yes i'll give way here and then on that
point he'll also be aware that
those care staff that provide
domiciliary care in people's homes
and they obviously provide care to many
people potentially going to many homes
during the day
um also caring and present
a similar challenge now my own
personal view is i think it would be
preferable in the first instance if we
could get those vaccination rates up by
education and persuasion i am prepared
if that isn't possible
following the precedent that we have in
the nhs for those who perform operations
and have to be vaccinated against
hepatitis
to agree to this matter but there is a
real issue with the millions of people
that provide domiciliary care
they're employed directly often and how
how is that going to work and provide
the level of protection required
yes we do propose to consult on this
point alongside the consultation
on the the mandatory vaccination as a
condition of deployment
uh in the nhs as he rightly says it is a
a complicated operational matter
the principle of vaccination for those
in a caring
responsibility is already embedded as he
says and indeed there is a history going
back
more than a century of uh of vaccination
being required in certain circumstances
and i think these are reasonable
circumstances so we will go ahead for
those who work
in care homes and we will consult for
those in domiciliary care
and on the nhs but i have
no proposals for and wouldn't expect
that we would then go any wider
and i'll give way well i i can
understand why we would want to
specially protect people in those
circumstances of course
but can he explain why it isn't possible
to maintain their right to choose not
to be vaccinated by instead requiring
say daily lateral flow tests for workers
in those industries
we do of course already have significant
testing but it's a matter of risk
and we know that the vaccine reduces
that risk
very significantly i'll give way i'm
grateful
to the secretary of state i won't be
joining in the lobbies
uh later on uh partly for
civil liberties reasons but i do agree
with what he's
saying about vaccination science and
technology committee
about four years ago looked at the level
of
flu vaccination in care homes and at
that time it was at about 20 percent
flu like covid is a killer of elderly
people
will he be looking not only to make it a
condition of employment for covid
vaccination but also for flu vaccination
uh yes we will for exactly the reason
that he sets up
grateful just on proving that you are
double vaccinated
there is still an issue between england
and wales and other parts of the uk i
just wonder when this is going to be
solved because obviously
everybody doesn't live in a
symmetrically sealed unit
well as somebody who grew up literally
right on the welsh border i entirely
understand that and
i'm working with baroness morgan the new
health minister in the uh in the welsh
government
uh to ensure we have more the the
interoperability that he calls for
um and um that's a significant piece of
work that's underway now we need to sort
this for
vaccine data flows but we also frankly
need to sort it for all health data
flows across the border
and use this particularly acute need
to actually change the policy and the
practices to sort this out
once and uh for all um mr speaker these
regulations in front of the house today
are there in order to pursue our goal as
throughout
to work to protect lives and get us out
of this pandemic as soon as safely
possible
and i commend the motions for the house
the question is motion number two as on
the order paper
jonathan jonathan ashworth thank you mr
mr uh mr deputy speaker and may i
begin by just paying tribute to our
much-missed
friend and colleague joe cox joe
was a internationalist and i know if she
was with us today
she would be rallying support not just
across this country but for her
international contacts
for a campaign to vaccinate the world
she would remind us that we will only
defeat
this virus through our common endeavor
and i think
all of us miss joe i want to send our
best wishes to our family
today mr deputy speaker we will support
the extension of restrictions in the
lobbies tonight but we of course do so
with a heavy heart but we are guided by
data
not dates and we have to recognize the
facts before us
the delta variant is 60 more
transmissible than alpha
and even with the current restrictions
in place the daily total of positive
cases has been rising the seven day
rolling average
over seven thousand per day compared to
around two thousand a day
uh in early may and this is beginning to
translate
into hospitalizations and with cases
doubling every nine days with it at the
moment it looks like hospitalizations
are also doubling
96 people with covid were admitted on
the fourth of june
nine died nine days later 187 people
were admitted
almost double if this continues to
double
within four four sets of doublings we
would be close to the april 2020
peak and given that we know there's
always a lag in the figures
we are no doubt like to see around 250
admissions a day
in 10 days time so we are seeing this
third
wave in the nhs and we need to do all we
can
to stop the hospitalizations rising
because this is a time of huge pressure
on the national health service
we've lost a number of beds over the
last 10 years and because of the need
for infection control measures
we have less general acute beds open
today in the nhs
as well we're facing a monumental
backlog in care 5 million on the waiting
list
over 385 000 waiting over 12 months for
treatment nearly 3 000 now
waiting over two years for treatment
and throughout this crisis we've said
the nhs wasn't
overwhelmed but it was only not
overwhelmed because of some of the
terrible choices that had to be made and
to be frank
i don't want to see the nhs forced to
make choices
between providing covert care and cancer
care
that's why we should listen to those nhs
leaders who have warned us about the
increasing pressures
on the nhs at the moment chris hopson
for nhs providers the nhs is running hot
at the moment dealing with backlog
recovery
and emergency care pressures the nhs
confederation
health leaders are very aware of the
damaging effects
that prolonged social restrictions could
have on the nation's physical health and
mental wellbeing
yet according to our survey the majority
of nhs leaders
are concerned about the risks that
lifting prematurely could have on the
nhs's ability
to of course i'll give way to the former
minister i'm just keen to explore with
him
i know the the official opposition's
position will be to support these today
but
would he be happy to see the terminus on
july the 19th or would he like to see it
maybe at the end of september
when the entire adult population will be
double jab or would he prefer to see the
end of next year when the g7 think the
rest of the world will be
vaccinated which would his instinct be
once of course i want to see terminus
day on the 19th
although i'm not sure if we are going to
see terminus day on the 19th because
the honorable gentleman who is uh um you
know he's always well informed will have
no doubt read the explanatory notes
which indicate that this four-week
period
is to assess the data and the four tests
will be applied
at the end of that four-week period that
is not quite the terminus day
that the prime minister and the
secretary of state have uh indicated
of only misleading to call it a terminus
date anyway even if we were to implement
um cessation of some of the measures on
the 19th of july there are still going
to be lots of other measures
which are going to exist including tests
and trades and maybe for quite
proper reasons but to mislead the nation
by constantly going on about freedom
days and terminus
is just a mistake my rebel friend
makes a a good point and of course i
want to see terminus day
i want to see freedom i want to get back
to doing the things that i enjoy
uh uh doing uh although i'm quite happy
to sit in a group of six and
pub i'm not sure if i've got more than
six friends mr uh mr deputy speaker so
it could have suited me
uh in many ways but generally more
generally i am
more generally more generally i am uh i
i'm just
i'm uh i i'm uh i see you've got one
best friend today secretary of state
um uh uh i am uh
uh uh i am keen to see terminus day
uh but but the interesting thing is this
the prime minister the chancellor duchy
the secretary of state
in recent days have tried to hint
that restrictions are coming to an end
by using this new phrase we have to
learn to live
with the virus like we live with flu
but the secretary of state or prime
minister haven't really outlined to us
what that means because they're trying
to suggest to us that it's all going to
go back to normal
but actually we put in place mitigations
to deal with flu yeah by yeah the
honourable gentleman was a public health
minister
he was very much involved in the flu
vaccination campaign we vaccinate
children
to deal with flu we put infection
control measures into our care homes
when there is
a flu outbreak there will have to be
mitigations in place
when we go back to living with this
virus
but the secretary of state has to
explain to us what those mitigations are
will we continue let me just finish my
point i'll let the honorable john come
back will we continue wearing masks
well the secretary of state needs to
explain whether we should or not
will we be supporting buildings to put
proper ventilation systems in place and
we've known about the importance of
ventilation
in dealing with respiratory viruses
since the days of florence nightingale
countries like belgium are now providing
premises and buildings with co2 monitors
to improve
their air quality will we be doing that
and the other thing about this virus is
that even when we vaccinate people and i
want to see us meet these various
vaccinates and
targets of course i do we do know that
some people will still be at more severe
risk
than they would be from flu there will
be people who will develop
long covert symptoms and for some people
those symptoms are beyond
achiness and tiredness we've seen people
lose hair people lose teeth
some people it is uh presented as
depression anxiety even psychosis
in some circumstances so living with
this
virus like flu or learning to live with
it ministers must explain to us exactly
what that means and they should also
explain to us it didn't come up
in the exchanges and i thought perhaps
one honourable member might ask the
secretary of state this but they didn't
uh is what are we going to do in the
winter
and perhaps the secretary of state or
the minister and responding to the
debate
can tell us if the secretary of state or
the minister
or department officials are putting
together plans
for restrictions this winter and whether
the secretary of state has developed or
discussed those plans
with any colleagues in whitehall i'd be
grateful as the secretary of state or
the minister could
tell us about that i'll go to the public
health minister and then the former
chief whit
just to conclude this then he is right
we had a battle royal with influenza
in the first year that i was in the job
and but the difference was we didn't
have any non-pharmaceutical
interventions our interventions
were about the take up of the vaccine
yes for children as well as for adults
especially the vulnerable
and one of our chief advisors the deputy
chief medical officer then
one professor chris whittie never
suggested masks or let alone
closing schools just a really good
rollout of the flu vaccine and we lost
22 000 people that year
never were those numbers rolled on bbc
news never did we know the r number
but there was a point where we accepted
an element of risk
in society and i guess that's the point
of my first intervention on the
honourable gentleman is
what is the element of risk that he is
prepared to accept because
that is what it comes down to our own
mortality is part of the human condition
we do accept it but we don't glibly
accept it because year by year
we're looking for improvements in
vaccinations and therapeutics and
medicines to push down
infection rates as low as possible so
even though
we are grown up enough to be aware that
sadly some people will die
from flu and pneumonia we do all we can
to avoid it
and that is what we'll have to do with
this but i don't want to see it done by
some of the
wider restrictions and lockdowns that
we've heard about which is why i'd be
interested to know
if the department has developed plans
for restrictions this winter and if the
secretary of state has been discussing
it
with whitehall colleagues or not
grateful
just on that point uh that the shadow
health secretary mentioned about those
restrictions um i i know that those
discussions are are going on because
i've seen documents from within
government with very detailed
um suggestions about what measures may
continue so
um and i asked the secretary about this
um when he uh
was in the commons earlier this week and
he didn't rule out
bringing in restrictions this winter
which is one of the reasons why
colleagues like
on our side of the house are very
concerned and why we're not going to
vote for these
regulations what i wanted to take him
back to though was his comments about
what chris hopson said about the nhs and
the fact that the nhs is very busy at
the moment because there is a danger
here and i'm very sympathetic to to
colleagues who work in the nhs you've
done a fantastic job
but i don't think we can get to a point
where we
restrict and manage society
in order to manage nhs waiting lists
i don't think that's the right way round
the nhs is here to serve society
if it's the case that we need to enable
it to do that we have to think of a way
of doing it
other than putting restrictions on the
rest of society i don't think that is a
sustainable
or a desirable position but it's the
logical consequence i think of what
chris hopson was saying
earlier this month i mean even though we
will find ourselves
in different lobbies this evening i
think there is more in common with us
than perhaps
uh uh we might expect i don't want to
see restrictions
uh remain in place any longer than they
need to be and i want to move to a
system
where we are trying to push down covered
infection rates by yes rolling out
vaccination as far
and as fast as possible to everybody but
putting in place
the proper framework so those that are
ill
or a contact of someone who has been ill
with kovid is able to isolate
themselves we do have a culture and the
secretary of state is referred to in the
past he's talked about how we all
soldier on in this country
and i dare say many of us in this
chamber i've certainly done it in
my last 20 years of working life going
into work with a sore throat or feeling
under the weather and so on thinking
well i'll just have a sort of
some paracetamol and i'll just get on
with it i mean things like this have got
to change because
although that sort of wrote may well
have been fine for me we
we now understand in greater detail that
it could have been very dangerous for
others so i think we've got to change
our attitudes but there'll be a lot of
people who still have to go to work
because they can't afford to stay at
home so again
we need decent sick pay uh sorted out
and one of the
things that was revealed in the the
morning politico
email was a leak of a government
document who said that the isolation
system is still not effective and that
is because we still don't pay
people sick pay and this is going to
become more of an issue because
presumably if testing traces to stay in
place
for uh the next year or so as my
honorable friend from the ronda
indicated
there will be people who've had two jabs
who will be asked to isolate themselves
who will ask themselves not unreasonably
if i've had two jobs
why do i need to isolate themselves so i
think this is going to become much more
of a challenge
and we're going to need a proper sick
pay in place but just to finally finish
the point
from the honourable member from
winchester
i want us to control the virus we're
doing things like sick pay for doing
things like proper ventilation support
by doing things like investing properly
in public health systems and local
primary care
systems because one of the things we
know about this virus like flu
is that it does disproportionately hit
the poorest
and the disadvantage because they're the
people who have to go to work or they're
the people where
oh it's in those communities where
significant long-term conditions
diabetes copd hypertension
tend to cluster which often makes those
people more vulnerable
to these types of respiratory viruses
the honourable member
the older gentleman are on the subject
of the poorest the most disadvantaged
what does he then make of the
observation made by the chief medical
officer recently
around the annual toll taken by smoking
the ill effects of smoking
he said that because he wanted to
compare and contrast the number of
people that we are losing saudi to covet
with those we lose every single year to
the ill effects of smoking
we've been prepared to countenance some
swinging restrictions on all of our
liberties
for the past 15 months banning smoking
for example
would be far less by comparison
and it is smoking that is driving up
health inequalities but i haven't heard
him comment on that yet
well i've not commented in my remarks so
far but i've commented in the past and i
absolutely agree
with the honorable gentlemen we need to
do more
to drive down smoking rates we need to
do more to deal with alcohol abuse we
need to do more
with the fact that too many of us eat
food which is high in
you know high in salt and sugar and i
am prepared to work with the government
to be to be more
interventionist on these matters so i
would look at uh
um you know levies and tax on the on
on tobacco than tobacco companies i
would invest more in anti-smoking
and public health facilities locally
some of which have been cut back sadly
because the public health grant
has been cut back so yes i completely
agree with the honourable gentleman
yes he's missed the point perhaps i
didn't make myself clear enough
the chief medical officer was
introducing that because he was trying
to explain that we're going to have to
live
with some level of risk we need to have
a discussion about the public's
appetite for risk if we're to live with
covet
and the reason he cited smoke at 90 000
a year
it's a good because it approximates to
the number of people we have lost
uh from covid so far uh in this pandemic
so we need to we do not agree we need to
have a discussion
about where we're where we're prepared
to pitch this
is it 22 000 which is a bad flu year is
it 90
000 uh which is what we lose every
single year
from the ill effects of smoking no i i i
understand the point the honourable
gentleman is making
some way similar to the flu point we
don't just glibly accept
smoking we take measures in society to
try and push down rates
now i don't think this house would want
to go as far as to
uh us to ban smoking out right despite
what any of us might
think as feel as individuals about
smoking but we do what we can
to push down smoking rates because we
want to reduce
the health the poor health outcomes from
smoking and that's what we'll have to do
with covid
we'll have to put measures in place to
mitigate
against the uh negative effects of covid
which i would argue
is around allowing people to to isolate
themselves with proper sick pay about
doing things around ventilation
and and uh giving local authorities
um more responsibility to perhaps
inspect premises where there isn't
proper ventilation standards in place
and obviously to resolve some of the
issues around contact racing that
still haven't been resolved 15 months on
so i do i do understand the point
that the honourable gentleman is making
and these makes it makes it well as as
always in this place
so uh before i was taken off course i
was quoting some of the health
organizations and the point is i believe
uh where where we are now in response to
this virus is that we should listen to
those health professionals
and take into account what they are
saying and and delaying the road map by
four weeks will hopefully
relieve the pressures on hospitals which
is why
where we are prepared to support the
restrictions
uh tonight in the lobbies because for me
i think if we
lifted all the restrictions now i fear
that that could be akin to throwing
petrol on a fire at this
moment so we will support the government
but of course uh mr speaker
mr deputy speaker we shouldn't be here
because and we are only here because
over the last eight weeks we have failed
to contain
the delta variant and have allowed it to
become
dominant now i've always i've always
i've always tried to keep i've always
tried to keep our dealings
uh civil in public and private with the
secretary of state
but not so it seems the prime minister
the right honourable gentleman now
forever branded
as hopeless hancock by his own leader
well for many of our constituents when
they'll be watching the news tonight
when they know that they fail to protect
our borders when they know that they
allowed this variant to take off and
when they saw
that restrictions are being extended i
think many of our constituents will no
doubt repeat
the prime minister's expletive-laden
sentiment about the secretary of state
tonight but we are being asked to
endorse these restrictions because they
failed to prevent this variant from
reaching our jaws rather than red
listing the delta variant
when it was needed they gave it the red
carpet
instead let me remind the house on march
24th
india's health ministry warned about a
so-called
double mutant variant on march 30th the
bmj warned that india's cases have taken
a sharp upward turn since march
and that india had the third highest
number of confirmed cases and deaths
from kobe 19.
on first of april the original b161 7.1
is designated
as under investigation by eight by april
2nd
the group the government puts the
pakistan and bangladesh on the red list
by not
india and in this time cases are running
at close to 100 000 a day
in india and thousands of people are
returning to the uk
from india the secretary of state
justifies his position
by saying that he didn't have the data
but he should have acted on a
precautionary
basis when he could see that the virus
was raging with a hundred thousand cases
a day
in india he should have immediately put
india on the red
list because the one thing that we know
about this virus
is if you don't get ahead of it it
quickly gets ahead
of you now the house is being asked to
extend these restrictions but there are
a number of pressing issues firstly
many of us have been contacted by
businesses in our constituencies
who are deeply deeply concerned about
the extension these restrictions
uh uh and for mark for my constituency
and leicester who have been through a
form
i've been living under a form of
restrictions uh more severe than other
parts of the country over the maybe
parts of greater manchester
this has been particularly devastating
so i hope the government will be putting
in place
full support for businesses like mine in
leicester and greater manchester
and elsewhere and the second issue which
we've touched on a little bit is whether
these restrictions will ever end or
whether the prime minister
has trapped us in hotel california where
we can never
leave july the 19th is talked about as
the terminus date but the explanatory
notes themselves
say that four tests will apply uh on
july 19th and that these four
weeks are used to gather more uh
data and the other thing of course is
that even with the vaccination program
uh going ahead and being uh and going
further and i
like the secretary of state i've had my
second job rearranged i'm looking
forward to
it in a couple of weeks time there will
still be a large proportion of the
population
who have had one job or no jab who will
still be vulnerable
to catching the virus and the virus can
still exploit that opportunity
to transmit it was a secretary of state
himself who said some weeks ago
that delta can spread like wildfire
amongst those who haven't had a jab
that will mean further disruption to
people's lives it will mean more people
need to isolate it could mean more
people
suffering from long covid now he said
when i put these points from a monday
that the logical conclusion of that is
that restrictions remain in place
forever on the contrary the logical
conclusion of that
is that you put the other measures in
place which will allow you to push down
infection rates basic infectious disease
control measures such as sick pay
such as isolation support 38 billion
pounds has been allocated to testing and
tracing and yet the numbers
using lateral flow tests have actually
gone down six weeks in a row
this is because we haven't got proper
stick pay for people and also
anecdotally we're also hearing that more
people are deleting the app from their
in their in their from their phones now
uh
mr mr deputy uh uh speaker
we will support these restrictions
tonight and we hope that the secretary
of state or the minister can give us a
commitment
that he will come to the house in two
weeks time and give us the update
on that data we hope that the secretary
of state
will give us a commitment to put in
place the other measures that will help
push down
infection rates but the sad truth is
that we have to
push forward these restrictions again
for another four weeks
because the secretary of state was
indeed
hopeless and failed to contain this
delta
variant
can i say that um we're going to have a
four-minute limit
um immediately but i think that's going
to be
reduced later on we've had a few
withdrawals so please don't assume that
the person um
uh that everybody is here on the list
that's number one number two
um of everybody contributing there's
only four contributing virtually today
so everybody else is physical which is
uh
i have to say very pleasing from the
chair uh i have to say
um and of course the four minute limit
is for uh from bench contributions
only so we'll call sir desmond swain
mr deputy speaker i never believed that
it was proportionate
even from the outset for ministers to
take
such liberties with our liberty
i always thought it was wrong for them
to take our freedoms
even though they believed that they were
acting in our best interests
in an emergency but by
any measure that emergency
has now passed and yet freedoms are
still withheld
and the government will not allow us to
assess for ourselves
the risks that we are prepared to
encounter in our
ordinary everyday lives the government
does not trust the people that it
governs
now many members of sage have been out
on the stage
there's a misnomer if ever there was one
but members of sage have been out
busily undermining public morale one of
them even
sharing her dystopian vision that we
must all
remain masked and distanced
in perpetuity a shocking
horrible prospect the fact is
that once the consequences
of this virus in terms of their
financial
and health impact have long
been addressed the moral
impact will remain the government
has set a disastrous precedent
in terms of the future of liberty
in these islands now i can understand it
if we were a communist
party but this is the party that
inherited
the true wisdom of the wig tradition
this is the party of margaret thatcher
who said
that liberty was indivisible this is the
party that only recently
elected a leader that they believed that
we believed was a libertarian
there is much on which we are going to
have to reflect
erin thompson thank you mr deputy
speaker
i'll be relatively brief in recognizing
that the
the public health motion here is
relating to the english uh
covert uh public health regulations so
we'll be addressing most of our comments
to the the second of the motions however
i think it is worth
noting and certainly picking up in a
number of the comments made by the
shadow secretary and and other members
in relation to what
they what for the outlook is beyond
covid that next week the scottish
government will actually be publishing a
paper setting out
what it hopes life after covert will
look like as we get back to
something normal and the the remaining
restrictions begin to be removed none of
us want to see
these restrictions in place any longer
than they have to be
but while there is a risk to public
health i think we do need to be very
careful and the scottish government have
been very very
minded to focus on the data and not the
dates
um which i have to say as seems to be
quite a marked difference in the
approach of of the two
given with there's such a focus on
freedom days and terminus dates
all having to be attached to a
particular date
rather than just looking at what the
data actually tells us
now i think as i say we none of us want
to see restrictions
longer than we need to but while we
there is still the risk we must continue
to do that
the vaccine rollout has been spectacular
nobody
can deny that but there are still so
many who we do need to continue to
protect
turning to the the second of the motions
mr deputy speaker obviously
i very much welcome the inclusion of
this motion to extend the
virtual proceedings i think it would be
unreasonable where
there is an extension for the general
public to to not have extended
such provisions in this place and many
times over the course of the last
year and a bit we've heard how we need
to make sure this place keeps stepped
with
the general public i would suggest that
keeping set with the general public
would also mean that we continue to look
at what
steps we could take to enhance ability
within this place as we go forward
as workplaces across the country will be
doing they are looking to different ways
of working and new
and different ways of adopting ways that
can encourage
uh participation from all and i do fear
that at some stage we may again be at a
place where we're disenfranchising some
members
that this particularly brings to my mind
that
it probably is a time and we perhaps
with this extension of governors
ourselves
the opportunity to re-examine some of
these points around medical
proxy voting i think there are some
members with
very particular medical situations that
are unique to them where a case could
very strongly be made
that a proxy vote would be appropriate
on a longer term than has been outlined
i'm not saying that we should be putting
in place something that makes it easy
for a minister to be given a proxy to
to be able to avoid a vote just because
it suits
this is about a very particular set of
situations where
a specific number of members do have
very unique
circumstances and we do need to take
account of that
i would also say that i i've raised this
previous
yesterday when these motions were
presented but
i do fear that given the variability and
the the the virus and the changes the
circumstances that can happen in it by
the nature of the fact that we've had to
have an extension at this point by
having an
end date to this at this part of our
recess
and effectively coming back in september
with no opportunity in advance of that
to consider what
may or may not need to be done at that
stage i think
does pose us with a slightly unusual
situation
in that should situation arise in
september where we need to do something
else
this place will have to return in full
numbers to effectively decide whether or
not we want to have
any further restrictions and i would
sort of urge some caution in that and
and ask for some consideration as to how
that could be managed because i think
that would be
a particular anomaly as i say workplaces
across the country are looking to how
they can adapt
so why wouldn't we and i think it's
appropriate so given the number of
members looking to to speak in this
debate i i will restrict my comments to
that thank you
so charles walker well thank you mr
deputy speaker mr speaker i wish to
try and be constructive about how we can
improve sage
now mr speaker as you know sage has huge
power
over our lives it has power over who we
hug and hold
it has power over which businesses open
and which businesses close
in essence it has power over who keeps
their job
and who loses their job and
mr speaker we too in this place have
great power
we have we have great power but our
power is matched to
accountability accountability is very
important in the exercising of power so
i want to
suggest some reforms to sage some quite
technical reforms
i think firstly there is need for
greater financial transparency
from members of stage from members of
sage sorry in line with that expected of
members of parliament so for example
i think when we look at sage members we
should be able to see what their
annual income is not only from their
substantive job
but also from their pensions accrued or
the pensions they might well
be in receipt of this is something that
is freely available
with all members of parliament i think
we should
we should also know constituents should
know
if they have any significant
shareholdings in companies in the same
way
that they know our constitution if we
have significant shareholdings in
companies
we could also look at whether they get
other forms of income
from rent for example now i'm not
suggesting for a minute
that this would include their spouses or
partners in the same way it doesn't
include our spouses and partners but
given members of sage are making huge
decisions that have huge financial
consequences for tens of millions of
people
it would be it is important that our
constituents know
whether or not the people making these
decisions
are sharing the pain or insulated from
the pain for example
in the case of young people many people
many sage experts say that young people
should should be working from home we
know young people are now
tied to their to their small kitchen
tables in their bedroom in miserable
environments the new dark satanic mills
working endless hours in appalling
circumstances
because people with nice gardens and
comfortable homes
think that's what they should be doing
there should also be far greater
personal
accountability there should be no more
here is sir mark walport
of sage but here in a personal capacity
nonsense he's there because he's a
member of sage and we should also
have elections to sage
so we could see sir mark walport
professor susan mitchey john edmunds
regular talking heads in our tv studios
challenged by people with a different
perspective
people like professor carol sakura
professor paul
dolan who is an expert on human behavior
and quality of life
professor ellen townsend who has a huge
interest in the welfare of children and
adolescents
who are now being plagued by anxiety and
eating disorders
i give way to my he's making a great
case with which i largely agree but will
he agree with me that experts are only
human and we've been in
to an extent asking the impossible of
them their risk averse they don't want
to be blamed for a disaster
they'll choose to give advice that's
cautious would he join me in
recommending to the prime minister the
reforms that i've put forward
to have competitive multi-disciplinary
expert advice with red team challenge
it's a fantastic and applausable
suggestion we need a diversity of voices
but of course if we had elections we
could get people elected from
independence age and we know what they
want
harder lockdowns tighter lockdowns and a
permanent end to freedoms
but mr speaker there is there is a there
is an alternative
there is an alternative to elections to
financial disclosure
there is an alternative and that is the
prime minister could say to members of
sage he could say this to them
he could say here it is you can either
advise me or you can
advise the today program sky channel 4
but you can't do both
you can't do both you can either be a
serious scientist
at this moment in time advising your
government or you can be a media talking
head
building a career outside sage but you
can't do both
and i think that is a perfectly
legitimate thing to do we would not
expect our generals
to give a running commentary on the war
undermining politicians it's just not
acceptable
it's just not acceptable to speak can
you imagine if the clerks of my
committee
that advisers might who advise my
committee
we're going out and briefing what they'd
like to see my committee do
pushing us into a corner all the time it
wouldn't be tolerable it wouldn't be
tolerated in this place
and it shouldn't be tolerated by number
10. so here it is
full financial disclosure from sage full
elections
or they advise the government
and if they don't want to do that and
advise tv studios they do that
but they don't do both yeah
thank you mr deputy speaker and ever
it's
an honor to follow the honourable
gentleman what i would say to what he's
saying is interesting point about sage
is we could do with full disclosure from
the government about all the facts that
they
are available to them uh on on kovit
this morning the science and technology
committee we were told
that vaccinations have saved 14 000
lives i have no doubt that that's an
accurate
figure but there are many figures that
have not been
given and as we said last time we
debated this
only one side of the equation is given
let me ask this question how many
lives have been lost in order to save
the capacity in the nhs and i think
when it comes to looking at the untested
people the untreated people from cancer
from heart disease and other diseases
we will find that those figures are of a
similar
if not greater magnitude than the people
who
have died from covid we should also
have transparency and open declarations
of what really happened with the 26 000
deaths in
care homes where untested people were
sent
to those care homes from from hospital
we should have disclosure about all
those people who were triaged by
age and were not treated or all those
people
in care homes who were not allowed uh
into
hospitals because they weren't taking
people uh
from from care homes there's a great
deal
more information that we require in
order to make a rational
uh decision about whether this lockdown
should continue i agree with the
honorable
just one second i agree with the
honorable gentleman
from new forest west i think it is that
what we have here
is the government asking for emergency
powers when there is no longer an
emergency i give way
to my colleague
i thank the honourable member opposite
for giving away he was at science and
technology with me this morning does he
share my disquiet
uh at the fact that the vaccine
effectiveness numbers that public health
england have published
of 96 against hospitalization for
advisor with two doses and ninety-two
percent
uh for us astrazeneca uh against
hospitalization
are much higher than the numbers that
have been plugged into the models that
imperial and the london school of
hygiene tropical medicine
have used to underpin uh the data that
the government is relying on
i do agree uh completely
uh that those are the numbers the real
numbers as opposed to model numbers or
the numbers that should have been
uh plugged into that model they would
have given a different scenario and
the honourable general makes my point in
order to come to rational decisions
about what risks
as a country we should take and what
risks individuals should take
we should have all the information up to
up-to-date
and available i think that if
the government has refused on a number
of occasions
to give that information out they have
run a campaign to scare people
into accepting the decisions
that the the government have made and if
i can go
uh back to the honourable gentleman
who's talking about elections
for sage at least the behavioral
psychologists
who advise the government have made a
public apology
that they say they've undermined their
own professional credibility
by joining in that campaign
of uh fear and i i wish the government
not only would
put out more information but
that they would also apologize for
frightening
uh people they shouldn't frighten the
electors and they certainly shouldn't
uh prime the people in this chamber for
taking people's liberties uh
uh away one of the things that has
annoyed me most in
terms of the last 15 months is when the
prime minister and the secretary of
state for health
stand up and say we instruct you
meaning the population to do various
things there is nothing in the
legislation
that would give the secretary of state
or the prime minister
the ability to uh instruct individuals
we live in a liberal democracy where we
pass laws
and those laws are enforced by the
police and then the courts
take a decision if there is a
prosecution not
where the secretary of state acts like
some kind of
uniformed minister of the interior
i will vote against this today we need a
more
direct debate on
on the issue and we need to as members
of search for
we need to have a straightforward
comparison
with real statistics about what risks
everybody
face okay events mr deputy speaker for
over 800 years this house has been
making decisions
on risk be it sending men and women to
war providing financial support
instigating reform in trades or even
laws and tonight's
vote boils down to an assessment of risk
essentially there are three options we
open on the 21st we delay
or we close and put more lockdown
measures back in now if we accept the
premise that we can't get rid of covid
we can disregard the reintroduction of
lockdown rules on the basis that
it's too risky to the economy to
non-coveted health and education
and even a tiered approach to deal with
regional variation
i don't think would be stomached by the
public
so that leaves us with two options open
as planned
or delayed now i've checked the data
like many of you on the dashboard this
morning
and it shows the seven day increase of
cases the average is 38.8
and hospitalization's increasing by 22
we also know that we vaccinated
79 of the population with one dose
57 with two doses but we also know
that no measure is a hundred percent
effective no mask is a hundred percent
effective and no vaccine is a hundred
percent effective
but we know if you put those measures
all together
the risk and this is all on the backdrop
against a delta variant which is
50 to 70 percent more contagious than
the alpha variant at christmas
which in turn itself was 50 to 70
more virulent than the original so
therefore this house
is being asked to make a judgment call
carry on opening as we are
risk further spread increase
hospitalization
or buy time see the trend get more
vaccinated
and reassess but of course at the
expense
of businesses and freedom
this is another sophie's choice but from
what i know from my constituents
they won't thank this house for a
four-week delay
but they will not forgive this house if
further lockdowns
return and so i will vote to support
the motions today but they still leave
certain sectors as zombie industries
not officially closed but not open
because there aren't enough customers
the travel the events the weddings
industry the nighttime economy so i urge
the government to consider
sector-specific
support now some listening might mistake
my words for the sound of a risk averse
man or a doctor who thinks too much
about health but in my day job my entire
career has been spent managing risk
from dealing with people's cholesterol
to a headache to working out if it's
stress
or a brain tumor but i did that openly
and frankly with my patients and now
this is what we need
from the government a debate on what is
the acceptable level
of covid risk there were 1500 deaths on
the uk
road and 25 000 deaths or serious
injuries last year
we as society accept this
risk we could ban all road travel and
stop
all deaths but of course we lose the
economic benefits
and our freedoms during the next month
i urge the government to bring forward a
debate on the risk
this house is prepared to accept
regarding covet
after all as i said at the start of this
speech
the house has been deciding this for
eight hundred years
why should it change now yeah christy
matheson
matthewson
he's speaker i'm sorry that secretary of
state's not in his place because he's a
chester lad and i was hoping to offer
him some cestrian
solidarity with the criticism of being
totally f star star
hopeless and given assurance i would
never have used f star star star
myself but he needs a bit of support
here because he clearly hasn't got very
much
on the other side there's the
announcement
and the process leading up to today has
been typical of this government as well
as handling
uh chaotic and totally lacking in
clarity
one minister says one thing uh lex the
same day i mean
another minister says something slightly
different or even wholly contra
contradictory the announcements drip out
inconsistently
in a series of leakings leaks and
pre-briefings and actually people would
understand the government's position i
think we've had news this afternoon that
we've got the highest number of cases
since february that has just been
announced people would understand
the government's position if the
government would level with them and be
more honest than there were than they
are
and the reason the government aren't
being honest is because of the series
ranks of the um
of the honourable members behind from
the libertarian
covert research group wing that are
putting undue pressure
uh understandably but ministers need to
stand up to it
instead um and and and and be a lot more
open and direct with people the other
thing we need of course
is a lack of the prime minister giving
his usual
bluff and bluster and bombast creating
false hope using phrases like my
honourable friend for ronda talked about
terminus day freedom day building people
up when he doesn't know that he can
deliver it
and then completely forgetting that he
said it in the first place it doesn't
help
the process in cheshire western chester
we've gone into enhanced measures
not quite sure exactly what that means
because it can mean anything that
the people want it to again because of a
lack of clarity
from the government they request they
suggest they advise
that people perhaps don't meet indoors
but what it does mean is
that because there's no instruction
there is no support
for businesses there's no support for
the nighttime economy there's no support
for the minister visitor economy which
chester is so important i was contacted
by jamie northrup from
alexander's live in chester it's a
brilliant venue it's a small venue
he's been working his socks off just to
keep afloat during this pandemic and
common with everybody else
who and honorable members can will know
this from their constituents
the hospitality sector and problems have
been doing everything that has been
asked of them
to meet restrictions to just to try and
keep afloat
um and um and and it's and i just often
hasn't happened
jamie talk to me about the music venue
trust six point plan for support
including extending the moratorium
on commercial evictions and cancelling
the introduction of business rates from
the first of july
he points out that there are three
issues in the six-point plan that
actually are in direct
power direct control of the government
to be able
to deliver and i urge ministers to look
very carefully at that it's all well and
good
asking advising cajoling but there has
to be support if we are going to extend
because so many businesses
will have planned will have put their
business planning um into place
uh to for the relaxation that was is not
now going to take place
and we need to give the extra support to
get over that final hurdle
i thought the honourable member
gentleman from bosworth who just spoke
talked he talked about um the the zombie
sectors those sectors that are alive but
aren't quite live it was a fantastic
phrase
absolutely uh pins this problem down and
there are other sectors
where they will not be able to pick up
straight away because of the time lag
in terms of the nature of their set of
their sectors aviation
travel and tourism aerospace i chair the
aerospace group
there has to be consideration for longer
term support for these
because they will not be able to pick up
straight away but
one final point we do not seem to be
getting enough actual physical supplies
physical doses of the vaccines
in cheshire western chester compared to
other areas can the minister look at
this please
because we don't seem to be able to be
getting our fair share
steve banker speaker i refer to the
declarations i've made
relating to the kovid recovery group no
one can deny
the brilliance of the government's the
nhs's vaccination program by mid april
the over 50s and the vulnerable had had
their first vaccination
and overwhelmingly now they have had
their second
that is reflected in the ons antibody
data
which is extraordinary shows
extraordinary levels for anyone over
50 50. antibodies are there in that
population
which is vulnerable to the disease that
though brings on to the best case
me onto the best case which can be made
for today's regulations and that is
that a small percentage of a big number
is still a very big number and it seems
to me that that is the best case the
government could make
but actually the ability of the nhs to
provide
other health care could be compromised
by admissions from a younger population
because
a small percentage of a big number is
still a big number
but the big problem with that the huge
problem with that is it concedes the
point that our liberties can be used
to manage the capacity of the nhs and i
can't concede that my honourable friend
right honourable friend from forrest of
dean
raised it earlier that's not the way we
should be going as a society
and i think if these restrictions which
we're extending had been proposed for
that purpose in the past
we would never have accepted them now in
wickham
people of course have been dutifully
washing their hands covering their faces
keeping social distancing's rules and
yet early in this pandemic i remember
one dear sweet lady older lady was
beside herself with anxiety at the
thought of having to go about her
ordinary life with her face covered
and look at us now taking it for granted
this is not normal this is the dystopia
which i stood here and forecast on the
day we went
into lockdown thousands of pubs and
restaurants
theaters have struggled by if not open
if open at all rather than just breaking
even
hardly breaking even we've been told by
uk hospitality that they're still
making a loss the truth is the
government hasn't got a systematic way
of showing us the cost benefit of the
measures that they propose
one of my colleagues earlier mentioned
professor paul dolan i've done a lot of
work with him i'll write to ministers
with a paper from him
he shows how to look not just at the
splash of policy but the ripples too
we really need to get this sorted out
embedded in a new public health act
together with reform to modelling
and also some changes to expert advice
which i raised in an intervention
one of the most important things i think
we've learned from mr cummings
it leaked whatsapp messages is that it
seems the government's been
significantly influenced by polling
i fear we'll we'll have had a real doom
loop here
between polling and policy making which
has driven us into a disastrous
position we now we now must not
tolerate lockdowns perpetually on the
table we must not tolerate a situation
going on where we and the police are
unclear
about what the law is and how it should
be applied i mean
imagine that you can hug but not dance
what madness
is this we can't tolerate a situation
anymore in which a government social
scientist
told the author of the book a state of
fear that the government had used
unethical techniques of behavioural
science
to deliver a policy which he said in his
own words smacks of totalitarianism
we have transformed this society for the
worst
we have put in place a culture and
habits which will take
years to shake off culture and habits
which distance people from one another
and diminish their quality of life the
quality of relationships that they have
with one another high streets are in
danger of becoming haunted alleyways
we are in danger of hollowing out and
destroying the entertainment industry
much that makes life
worth living today's vote will go
through it's a foregone conclusion but
as one of my other honorable right
honourable friends said
was he implied if the conservative party
does not stand for freedom under the
rule of law
in my view it stands for nothing we have
got to have a turning point
we've got to recapture a spirit of
freedom
thank you very much mr deputy speaker it
feels a little bit like groundhog day
another month another debate on covert
regulations
yet we really shouldn't be here having
this debate today for people and
businesses up and down the country this
four-week delay to fully restoring our
freedoms
is a huge and very costly blow yet the
sacrifices that continue to be demanded
of the british people are not being
coupled with the support that they need
to do the right thing
and that is why liberal democrats will
not be voting with the government
tonight on the public health provisions
and whilst we support the motion on
continuing the hybrid
proceedings in this place i would gently
ask the minister why it is the
government thinks we
as parliament need to continue meeting
in a hybrid way
whereas councils up and down the country
have been forced to meet in person
often at great cost when they're already
under huge amounts of pressure
as my liberal democrat colleagues and i
have been saying for the past six months
the way to restore our freedoms must be
three-pronged
vaccination test trace and isolate and
robust border controls
and the point has already been made
countless times that the reason we're
here is because ministers undoubtedly
failed
completely on the last of those three
points by putting india on the red list
far too late for political reasons
allowing the delta variant to be ceded
into the community
but even once the secretary of state
recognized it as a variant of concern we
know there was a 17-day delay
in designating it as such which meant
surge testing
commenced far too late that cannot
happen again
so mr deputy speaker the situation we
find ourselves in
was avoidable ministers must take full
responsibility
for having to delay the lifting of
restrictions next week and part of that
responsibility is to support people to
do the right thing
with businesses on their knees jobs are
at risk and many of the self-employed
have yet to get a penny of support
hospitality
events weddings culture tourism and
travel industries are on their knees
even after domestic restrictions are
lifted we know that the travel sector
will have to continue to bear the brunt
of restrictions given the biggest threat
to our full reopening
in the uk will be variants brought back
in through international travel
so the complete lack of a bespoke
package of support for this
these industries beggars belief
now if we want to restore our freedoms
fully next month as the prime
minister has promised us and allow our
economy to thrive again
then testing every potential case
tracing every contact and supporting
self-isolation is absolutely critical
experts have been calling for better
financial and practical support for the
past
year and finally the penny dropped
earlier this month for the former head
of test and trace
that supported self-isolation was the
missing piece
yet still there has been no
comprehensive package announced to pay
people their wages to self-isolate
provide accommodation if necessary
and support those with caring
responsibilities this is the way to
break chains of transmission and to stop
new outbreaks in their tracks it's also
an
awful lot cheaper than blanket
restrictions
now learning to live with this virus as
i believe we absolutely must
requires a proper strategy and an action
plan not hoping for a fair wind
it brings together the uk's
world-leading genomic
sequencing capability with traditional
public health test and trace
at local at a local level coupled with
the right support
our public health directors up and down
the country are crying out for this
they will continue to be our front line
for managing this virus
as we learn to live with covid let's
give them the tools they need
and not be back here again in a month's
time asking for a further delay
or worse still months down the line be
asked to reintroduce restrictions
congratulations on your well-deserved
recognition in the queen's birthday
honours list
dame andrea ledson thank you mr deputy
speaker
and isn't it wonderful to see so many
colleagues in the chamber
having a proper debate and it is really
interesting to hear what colleagues have
to say
and i have to add my own deep concern
about
any restrictions on people's liberty and
frankly
if we weren't already in step three of
lockdown anyway
i cannot imagine that anyone in this
place would today
vote for four weeks of restrictions on
businesses
on weddings on church congregations and
yes on young people's
end of school year celebrations with the
current data that we have
but nevertheless i'm going to disappoint
some of some of the colleagues
in this place by saying i will with a
very heavy heart
support the government trusting that the
government
is determined as we've been assured
by my right honourable friend the
secretary of state for health that if
possible
those restrictions will be lifted after
two weeks and not four weeks i urge them
to do that but i want to use these very
short remarks to raise a few specific
questions on behalf of my constituency
and others firstly there are many
businesses in the hospitality sector
that are open
but unable to make a profit because of
the social distancing rules
can these be relaxed a bit in this last
few weeks
surely we can do that secondly
many employers in hospitality and other
sectors
are now desperately trying to recruit
staff through job centres
and yet i'm told by businesses in my
patch
that many people are not responding to
offers
for interviews and i don't know if other
colleagues are finding that as well but
clearly
what businesses in my area are concerned
about is the
long period of enforced lockdown and
enforced inactivity
is leading to an issue of motivation and
sometimes it's just easier to stay at
home
rather than get back out there again
what are we going to do
many colleagues have talked about the
success of frightening people into
staying home
surely we're going to need something to
help people
to feel motivated and to want to get
back out there to work
to get our economy going again and to
help themselves
recover from this difficult period
thirdly
my constituency is home to silverstone
and the british grand prix
and it is due to take place from july
the 16th
to the 19th so can my honorable friend
assure me that this iconic world famous
event
surely one of the best of british can it
go ahead with a capacity crowd
albeit subject to covet testing fourth
i was pleased that the government has
listened to the many wedding businesses
and couples
looking to tie the knot and have agreed
to let weddings of any size go ahead
subject to social distancing
but as colleagues have said and as my
honorable friend will appreciate for
many couples
being able to hug but not dance you
can't have a band
you've got to socially distance that's
not the kind of big day that they wanted
for themselves
and their families so can he reconsider
this and finally
my novel friend will realize that school
and university students are now faced
for the second year in a row
with no end of year celebrations no
parents days no
prize givings in other words none of the
real rights of passage
that means so much to so many people can
we look at this again in these last few
weeks
it's been such a long haul and as i've
said i will
reluctantly support the government but i
do
urge the front bench to show more
flexibility
during this final few weeks so that some
of the joys of summer can light up
people's lives once again
sarah owen thank you mr deputy speaker
what a mess a hopeless border policy
a hopeless promise of freedom day and a
hopeless
government left ducking for political
cover
we may have grown used to it by now yet
another letdown
from this hopeless government during
this pandemic which at times has seemed
endless we've been here before with the
prime minister and yet it's still hurt
every time
mr deputy speaker businesses in luton
north which still can't reopen
are left now without any hope families
still separated after months and months
and young people not being able to do
all the fun things that young people
should be doing
just like when government let us down in
december yet again
it's all beginning to look a lot like
christmas
an offer of freedom being dangled in
front of people by a gung-ho
hopeless prime minister only for it to
be pulled away from us at the last
minute
when his bumbling and blustering gets
the better of him
we'll turn the tide on coronavirus in
three weeks he said
it'll all be over by christmas he said
june 21st will be our freedom day he
said
people in luton north understand that
this delay is necessary to slow the
spread of the delta variant
but it is a bitter bitter pill to
swallow for the couples having to
rearrange their wedding plans
the birthday celebrations missed the
people with loved ones abroad who will
have to wait even longer to see them
all people wanted all along from the
prime minister
is for him to be up front and honest
about the difficult situation our
country's in
at times of crisis the country's not
looking for a funny best mate
they're looking for a leader but instead
we've got a prime minister
who is too scared to tell it how it
is and it didn't really have to be this
way
on this side of the house we've been
warning about the hopeless situation at
our borders for
over a year the health secretary
admitted it
himself last week to the health select
committee that strong border policy
has to be part of planning for any
future pandemics it's time
for government to finally get a grip on
the border
and stop new and dangerous variants
delaying
our freedoms and to stop over promising
and under delivering now let me finish
by coming back to that word hopeless
we know now that the hopeless prime
minister
thinks he has a hopeless health
secretary
but what i think is absolutely obvious
now is that at points in this pandemic
when people
were getting sick families losing loved
ones and businesses going to the wall
this hopeless health secretary the
hopeless chancellor and the hopeless
prime minister
have been more focused on playing
politics in downing street struggling to
contain
all of those egos in one room than they
have been on the priorities of people in
luton north and across the country
when doctors and nurses were uncovered
wards in bin bags because there wasn't
enough ppe
when families had to have christmases
eid new year separated from the people
they love
when families were grieving the loss of
loved ones
downing street was in chaos and the
prime minister was not focused on them
he was instead focused on slating the
health secretary on whatsapp
i expect this from squabbling teenagers
not supposed leaders
people in luton north and across the
country deserve better than this
for this to be the final delay on our
road back to freedom this government
finally needs to get
grip of both themselves and this virus
the british public have done their bit
but this hopeless government has been
found wanting again
bradley thank you very much mr deputy
speaker and can i join you
in congratulating my right honourable
friend on her very well-deserved honor
she is a marvelous marvelous example of
a dame and i've been very very pleased
to call her my right honourable friend
she and i know that the art of
government and the art of being a
minister
is balance it is a taking
conflicting lobby groups and interest
groups and
analyzing them and assessing them and
working out
what is the right decision to take in
the
interests of the country that's in the
interest of the money that the
government can
spend taxpayers money it's not our money
but also where the resources of
government must go
and it's a very difficult job that
balance means that competing interests
all come in and they will
explain why their interest is the one
that matters
and they're not interested as to whether
the interest of someone else
will be affected by their interest and
actually
ministers are probably doing quite a
good job if nobody's terribly happy
because it probably means that they're
catering to all interests a little bit
now my fear throughout this whole
uh sorry saga of the pandemic and i do
pay tribute to the work that ministers
have done they have done
an incredible amount of work and they
have acted in the best interest of the
country
but follow the science has become the
mantra
and sometimes simply following the
science
is not enough because the science
is looking for one outcome and one
single thing and it is really reassuring
actually to have heard ministers over
the last few days
say that we will have to accept that
this is an endemic virus that we will
have to learn to live with it
because there was a time that all we
heard was that we would be actually
eliminating this virus and we simply
can't
do that and i would ask that ministers
think very hard
about not just the science but also the
interests of people
because we've been told for so long that
we must do
just essential activities and for a long
time that was merely
sleep eat drink and possibly go out for
an hour for exercise
well life is more than that life is so
much more
than the essentials life is those
weddings
with dancing and greeting loved ones
life is being able to see loved ones in
hospital when they are sick
something we've not been able to do
throughout covid
life is about attending the british
grand prix and many other occasions life
is about
the joy that you can get from these
these
occasions and events and that joy
is constantly being we're constantly
told we can't have that joy
because it will impact on the science
now the government has to start to
celebrate
and take advantage of the vaccine
program
we have got the most successful vaccine
program in the g7
something that i hope the prime minister
i'm sure the prime minister last week
uh reflected on i'm very proud that in
the north staffordshire
clinical commissioning group which i
share with my honourable friend from
newcastle underlying
we have the highest level of
vaccinations anywhere in the country
we need to start to get reap the
benefits of that vaccine program
so with a heavy heart i'm afraid to say
to the minister that i cannot support
the government this evening because i
cannot find a way to explain to my
constituents
why the things they are looking forward
to getting back to doing
can't have to wait and i understand i
absolutely understand
how it will have been put to the
minister this minister it will cost
lives if you do not do this minister
this will cost lives i understand that
that's how it will have been put
but we have to accept that we cannot
save every life
and i might have been willing i might
have been able to be persuaded
if the government was able to support
those businesses
that are unable to open but that's that
support is simply
not there the weddings industry the
hospitality sector
nightclubs so i'm afraid that whilst i
have a heavy heart i will not be able to
support the government although i will
on the procedural matters which i'll
just say before i sit down listen to
speak sammy wilson
and like the member for september
morelands i will not be supporting the
government this evening
but i will not be with a heavy heart it
will because i have a real conviction
that what is being done and the approach
that the government has made
on this issue is wrong and we have heard
it again here today
and we heard it yesterday from the prime
minister that the very basis
of pushing and promoting this policy
is to instill fear into the hearts
of people across the united kingdom
listen to them the prime minister
yesterday we
have to delay this because this new
variant
could kill people in ways we can't
foresee
or we we we don't understand
the same old message if you do not
obey these restructur restrictions
then you're in danger either of dying
yourself
or your relatives dying and you can't
put your nose out the door
you can't do the things you want to do
in normal life
because you'll there's a real danger
you'll die
even though of course the statistics
show that
even of those who contract coronavirus
a very few a very small proportion less
than
0.3 0.3 percent
actually died and of those even
the world health organization has said
that many of those deaths
may not even be a tribal coronavirus
anyway
if you've been tested for coronavirus 28
days before you died
in a car accident you will still qualify
as a coronavirus death
and the so the statistics themselves
have been
even used in a way to try and reinforce
the message of fear
now i want to just make two points um
here
today mr uh deputy speaker the first is
this
that if we follow the logic of what we
heard from the minister
and the prime minister over the last two
days
then we will never get away from the
restrictions
that we are living with at present
because
the minister has admitted that we will
have to live with coronavirus
and we know that the virus itself
will mutate so we're going to get
different versions of it
and if we get different versions of it
we'll be told that this verse is
different than the last person that's
more dangerous it's more contagious
it leads to more deaths it leads to
higher infection rates or whatever
so there's justification for keeping the
restrictions in place
and indeed we heard from the minister
today not only the current restrictions
but we know that we're not going to have
further restrictions
in the future if you work in the care
sector
you're only forced to have a vaccine
vaccination he didn't answer the
question but i assume
that if you visit anybody in hospital or
a care home
you're going to prove you have a
vaccination and if you if you
are a peripheral worker are you going to
have to have the vaccination
so we can see already that the
government is thinking
of people have accepted these
restrictions
there will be other things in the future
which are going to be uh forced on them
the second one is this
that the the minister said he was going
to follow the data
well let me tell them some data
unemployment my constituency
has gone up by more than a hundred
percent as a result of restrictions
businesses are going under between now
and what is called termness day many
people will find their employment
terminated
their business terminated their
livelihoods terminate
and for those reasons i will not be
voting for these restrictions tonight
thank you mr deputy speaker i think
throughout this process it's been
heartbreaking debilitating
wearing so to be here again talking
about a further four-week extension
is absolutely the worst possible outcome
for so many of us
it's so so disheartening but i say this
knowing that i will be supporting
government tonight and i'm interested
actually unfortunately to see that my
constituency neighbor the honourable
member for blakely and broughton is no
longer in his place
because he made a very elegant speech
talking about why he couldn't support
these measures on the grounds of civil
liberties
and i wanted to remind him that about a
quarter of his seat is actually in the
city of sulphur where i was a councillor
for a while
uh the city's motto is south's populist
supreme elect the welfare of the people
is the highest law
the infection rates in greater
manchester which are some of the highest
in in the entire country
are highest in manchester and salford
which is what his seat straddles so he
cannot say that he's putting the welfare
of the people in his constituency at the
highest level
and from there i just wanted to turn to
um actually something that was quite
elegantly brought up by the
member for luton north where she was
talking about wanting to get the
politics out of this and i i completely
agree with that
um i do which is why it was so
frustrating yesterday that in the
manchester evening news the league
member for health on rochdale borough
council
uh was dismissing all of the vaccination
program as a gimmick and a slogan
and was talking about oh sorry rather
hinting that the government was
withholding
vaccines from certain areas i think
anybody with the slightest idea about
how
logistics works knows that this is rate
limited purely by supply
so what i would say to members is we've
got four weeks to nail this down now
we can't have another extension we can't
keep going through this process
and we are going to have to work
together we're going to have to stop
sniping at each other and trying to make
little jives
or a little point here or there there
are people who are depending on us to do
the right thing
now thank you very much richard bergen
thank you mr deputy speaker and this
extension
is sadly necessary so i'll be voting for
it tonight
but once again this government's
failures have meant longer
restrictions have become necessary just
as has been
more economic harm than should have been
necessary
more human suffering than was necessary
time after time the governments
got it wrong think back to last summer
last summer we had very low case levels
the expert said it was a chance a chance
to crush
the virus but the governments did the
opposite in cases
spiraled out of control in the autumn
as cases rose again the government
locked down
far too late and released far too early
leading to tens of thousands of
avoidable
deaths and now when warned about the
risk
posed by new variants the government
refused
to close the border all because the
prime minister
wanted to go to india to pose
with president modi now the government
claims that only hindsight can spot this
pattern
but that's simply not true the
government
were warned time and time again
they ignored the warnings in the words
seemingly put into writing by the prime
minister
it's been effing useless but it's not
funny it's not a joke so many people
have lost their lives and it's now
necessary to elongate
the misery further because of the
government's
unnecessary failures now the
government's
now saying that we should and i quote
live with it
now i don't agree we should be
suppressing
the virus that doesn't mean more
lockdowns
to tackle this virus the government
should finally
put in place the basic public health
measures
it has refused from day one alongside
the vaccine
we need decent sick pay for people who
need help to isolate
we need to kick out the profiteers from
test and trace
we need to invest properly in local
health teams to do
effective tracing the failure to sort
out
these public health measures has led to
over a hundred thousand
needless deaths and it's prolonged
economic suffering
and it's prolonged that can take the
curtailment of our lives
and if we don't suppress it now through
test trace isolate and support
it risks hundreds of thousands more
cases
many thousands more hospitalizations
with huge pressure on our national
health service
many more will suffer from long covid
already
400 000 are it creates conditions for
new variants perhaps
even those invulnerable to the
vaccine so i call on the government
today to finally
finally sort out sick pay at real living
wage levels
government ministers claim i think it's
very interesting that the reason they
refuse to properly
financially support people to isolate
when they have
covid is that they believe that people
would abuse
the system it's no wonder given how they
behave
they think so little of other people
just because the tory party
is gaming the system to help their
super-rich donors
with these covered contracts it doesn't
mean that working people
should stoop to their level and working
people wouldn't
stoop to their level this government's
failure to support people with covid
is a moral outrage and it's creating
a public health crisis a public health
crisis
of which this government should be
ashamed
i'm voting for the extension tonight
because it's necessary
without government failure it wouldn't
have needed to happen
speaker i'm afraid that the former
speaker
is going to be uh very disappointed
because we are going to have to live
with covert
like we have to learn to live with every
other infectious disease that exists in
the world yes we try to suppress it yes
we try to deal with it but we're going
to have to learn to live with it
viruses you may be surprised to know
have been around 400 million years a lot
longer than us
guess which one's winning the darwinian
race now
when we do uh have to uh
make decisions i think one thing is very
clear that
up till this point the aims of the
medical profession and the government's
advisors and the aims of the government
have been broadly similar
but they're going to have to diverge at
some point because the medical
profession will always want to see the
rate of
infection brought down to the smallest
level possible at whatever cost
but the government has different
considerations the government needs to
ensure that the rest of the health
service
is able to operate properly that the
economy is moving
and that the social and uh well-being of
the population
is looked after that is why the aims are
different and and while i'm at it i have
to say
mr depp speaker in a private note i am
sick to death
of the government's so-called advisors
coming on tv and giving their individual
views rather than giving advice
to the government on a confidential
basis if they want to be stars
of sky news let them leave sage and let
them uh
carve their own path now
on what basis will we decide uh when we
have
this divergence now the first thing to
say is that
the variant is not going to be a reason
for keeping lock down because the
variant
may be more transmissible but that's
irrelevant if it's not causing more
hospitalizations
or more deaths and we already heard from
public health england
that the two vaccines the pfizer and ox
astrazeneca
can cope as well uh as uh with the
the new variant the indian variant as
they can with the kent variant so
we don't need to hear about the variant
argument because i don't think it holds
water
what matters is who is being
hospitalized and where
uh are the hospitalizations are a result
of young people who have not yet had the
vaccine who may be at risk because of
the increased
transmissibility of the new variant or
as it is people
as we've seen in some parts of the
country who have been offered the
vaccine but for one reason or another
chosen not to get it what we cannot have
is the country being held to ransom by
any groups who have been offered
a vaccine but have chosen not to take it
uh that is utterly unacceptable now
it seems to me that the essence of the
government's case is this and if my
only friend wants to intervene to to
confirm it it's this
that the government strategy was based
on a single vaccine strategy
in the belief that if enough people got
it the efficacy was high enough
that we could unlock at that point but
it seems to me that the evidence that we
was published by public health
yesterday probably in health england
yesterday that the pfizer vaccine
was 94 effective against hospitalization
after one dose
but astrazeneca is only 71 percent after
one dose and takes the second dose
to get up to 92 percent and it seems to
me what the government are telling us
and i wish they would be clear about
this is that what they need is a little
more time
to get the people especially with the
astrazeneca to the second dose
to get the level of protection against
hospitalization that we have against
pfizer
if the government presented their case
in this way it would be an awful lot
easier
for the rest of us to give the
government our support because it would
be a clear
rationale for it and the other thing
i'll say is this
we need to have a clear assurance that
this two-week review point
is not applied to buy support in the
house of commons but as a genuine review
of the data
where we will see within a couple of
weeks whether um this hospitalization
uh rate is increasing or not and
if the government gives us a clear
assurance that this two week is a real
review
and that we can achieve the full relief
of the lockdown
at that point then minster might be able
to buy us by a little
support uh from his own benches this
evening
video link time since i've said that
neil hanvey thank you mr deputy speaker
well uh it feels like we've entered yet
another episode of hancock's half hour
but
unfortunately it's laughable for all the
wrong reasons
the first motion uh on the debate today
indirectly
uh is relevant to scotland and
microcoding cowboy constituency
and without independence scotland will
continue to suffer the consequences of
uk government's
hapless leadership on covet travel
agencies in my constituency have another
month
of pouring money down the drain and
another month with no
tangible support from government that
first motion is england only so alba
members will abstain
on that principle but to those who have
suffered
loss of life and bereavement the
government's response of repetitious
braggadocious claims at every juncture
must be disheartening it's more
indicative as i said earlier today of a
dell boy britain
everything will be fine because we're
british
is precisely why we find ourselves in
this position
this government have put political
priorities over public safety
there's been a lack of action on border
control at the start of the pandemic
and with the identification of the delta
varian
they've allowed new variants to enter
and seed and
weekend's failure by the uk prime
minister to lead the g7 to invest in
vaccines and cash
in line with world health organizations
identified
need is absolutely unforgivable
there has been an unwillingness to
listen to learn and respond
chaotic messaging abandonment of testing
in march 2020 instead of using that
nadar
of the pandemic to expand testing
the secretary of state has continued in
his overconfidence and
on the and in the field lateral flow
test devices
and the chaotic education policy
has only made things worse there are
continued huge gaps in support driving
poverty and disadvantage
in the face of repeated warnings and
these are not just my concerns many have
been raised in the prestigious
uh british medical journal not every
misstep can be mitigated by the
effective work of kate
bingham's vaccines task force recently
the secretary of state supported my
calls for surveillance across a range of
indicators to beat the virus
but vaccines are not foolproof
the g7 chair opportunity was an
unforgivable moral failure
vaccines cash but also robust
international surveillance is urgently
required
the government's growing propensity to
ignore scrutiny of parliament
is absolutely staggering and now the
honourable member right honourable
member for north somerset derides
scrutiny of experts in the media
it's been never clearer than with their
vote dodging reduction in overseas aid
and that will not be forgiven this is a
global
and dynamic challenge the complete and
adequate response from the g7 summit
risks the development
of ever more virulent variants in light
of that failure and leadership from the
prime minister can we get
straight answers probably not
what action is the secretary of state
taking to secure our public health
by working to meet those who targets
for vaccines cash and surveillance
any return to normality will only happen
when we're all safe
thank you robert sims
point of order dr liam fox deputy
speaker i wonder if it'd be possible for
you
to convey to mr speaker the need that
while we're still
in the restrictions we have in
parliament we need to try to find ways
when we are able
to intervene with the contributions
being done by video because otherwise we
are unable to challenge
the sort of views of the scottish
nationalists who claim that the problems
they suffer
in the covert pandemic are a result of
the the united kingdom government's
actions
when they themselves have the same
powers to uh to deal
with them in scotland had they chosen to
do so differently but they haven't
i'll make absolutely certain that the
request
that the right honourable member has
made is presented to the speaker and i'm
sure that
he will respond in his usual fashion so
robert sims
the pandemic has been a massive
challenge to
the british government and i have to
think the prime minister and the senior
ministers
uh given the uncertainties that they
faced have done a pretty good job
and they certainly in terms of the
vaccination program
have proved to the world that britain
can do go alone and can do
a lot to safeguard its population when
it uses its science
and its ability to get things done but i
do
still have the view and i i was when the
road map was unveiled
i i thought to myself well at least that
stops me voting against the government
again
until we get to the point when the
government have delayed the opening up
i do think this is a matter of balance
the matter of judgment
my view is that most of the senior
ministers who took this decision need a
damn good holiday
because if you actually look at the data
if you look at what's happening in the
country
the restrictions are totally out of
kilter with with the
uh sense of the problem let me take the
south west of england there's 5.6
million people in the southwest of
england
sorry could you face it's because your
voice isn't being picked up by the
microphone and hand side can't hear you
5.6 million people in the southwest of
england there are 23 people in hospital
there are two in icu endorse it where
there's nearly a million people
we have one person in hospital and yet
hundreds of couples that want to get
married businesses that want to be
viable
people that want to get their lives back
in order
i just think that balance is wrong and
uh we have most of the population now
insulated with vaccination
we may not totally break the link
between people going into hospital
but there's over a hundred thousand beds
in the nhs
one percent are taken by covered
patients
now it might go up to two percent we've
already got
uh experts on tv saying well in order
for the
nhs to catch up we may well have to keep
restrictions for longer
i just think this is unacceptable to the
british people
restrict i'm perfectly willing as a
conservative to accept restrictions
when hundreds and thousands of people
are dying and we're dealing with a a
virus that we don't understand but we
have sort of got to the point
where we've won the battle and there
will be variance there will be
challenges
but i think we have to get on with
normal life and i think the points made
by my right honourable friend the
the member for north somerset are
perfectly right if if it's simply
because
uh this we need to get second doses in
if that has been explained
i think we might be a little bit more
relaxed but we're already here and today
if you look at the expansionary notes
that actually it's a review of data in
two weeks or in four weeks
not necessarily a release date we need
to get people's freedoms back
we can't save everybody but what we've
done is save thousands and thousands of
lives
now we need to safeguard employment
safeguard businesses
safeguard people's personal
relationships and as i
started off by saying i think the
government have done a pretty good job
the vaccine
program is outstanding we now have to
take the dividend from that to get
people back to normal life
when they queued up with their
enthusiasm to get that jab in their arm
they thought that meant things would
come back to normal they did not expect
that they would be in with him further
restrictions
going on and on and on so i think the
june the 21st we should have lifted or
restrictions i hope
and i pray that the government in two
weeks time
look at the data again and set people
free
thank you mr left speaker like many
members who represent some of the
highest
infected areas during this pandemic my
own constituency of stockport has been
in a locked down of some form for more
than a year along with the vast majority
of greater manchester
while the people of stockport have
worked tirelessly to keep our community
safe
they have repeatedly been let down by
this government as a result thousands of
workers risk losing their jobs as
businesses struggle to survive with
insufficient financial support packages
and an endless cycle of lockdowns and
restrictions
that have that has pushed our high
streets to to breaking point
i would also like to uh hear the the
minister tell this house today
why 15 months into this pandemic this
government has failed to take any
meaningful action to help businesses
schools
and leisure facilities improve
ventilation when we have long known that
this is an airborne virus
he will no doubt tell me that the
treasury has spent billions on furlough
payments and support schemes
but businesses know the reality namely
that measures such as furlough payments
are little more than a drop in the ocean
when it comes to their bottom line and
ability to plan long term
to survive this pandemic far more needs
to be done if we had to avoid our
economy no starving and millions across
the uk
ending up unemployed as we've heard
today the government has also repeatedly
failed my constituents and millions of
others
around the country on the issue of
health care indeed we've already heard
today what the prime minister really
thinks of the health secretary
and perhaps uh it will be the only time
the only time in this house that i admit
to agreeing with him
mr deputy speaker we are witnessing a
crisis in our health care system
and the government cannot simply blame
the pandemic
indeed in the months before the kerbit
crisis began a source at stepping in
hospital in my town
told the manchester evening news that
patients where i quote
stuck outside in ambulances with every
corridor full of patients on trolleys
and many forced to wait up to 24 hours
to be seen for treatment
this is not default financial workers
who have performed directly throughout
this pandemic
the blame must be laid squarely at the
door of this government following a
decade of chronic underfunding of our
health service
the latest set of official nhs figures
have revealed that record numbers of
people are on hospital waiting lists
across greater manchester stockport ccg
which covers my constituency has more
than 37
000 people waiting for vital hospital
treatment
this is the highest level in the region
which is completely unacceptable
and this is compounded by the fact that
most are having to wait at least
18 weeks for treatment my constituents
aren't alone across the country more
than 5 million people are now waiting
for routine treatment
such as hip and knee operations which is
the highest level on record
go of it is of course a factor but the
reality is that this crisis has followed
years of chronic underfunding by this
conservative government
and we are now unfortunately having to
reap what they've shown
a further contributory factor in the
rising number of infections
is the scandalous lack of sick paper
workers who are forced to self-isolate
feel unwell or take time off to look
after loved ones who are ill
they're being punished for following
government guidance and in many cases
are left with no alternative
but to continue to work while
potentially infectious due to lack of
available support
the unison northwest survey recently
revealed that 80 of care workers
will continue to receive just 95 pounds
per week statutory sick pay
if they are ill or following the
government's advice to self-isolate or
shield themselves or loved ones
the right thing to do would be to give
them full pay so i asked the minister
does he accept that his government's
failure to introduce proper financial
support for people to self-isolate
and proper sick pairs contributed to our
failure to keep on top of the delta
variant
and has led to delay in lockdown
restrictions delay in lifting lockdown
restrictions
we were expecting today as the prime
minister's former senior adviser
recently said
fundamentally there was no proper border
policy because a prime minister never
wanted a proper border policy
our workers businesses and most
vulnerable society are now paying the
price for this want and disregard of our
nation's health
thank you mr speaker simon fell
thank you mr deputy speaker i don't
think anyone
envies the task and the decisions that
this government and this prime minister
have to make
we've got a vaccination program that's
the envy of much of the world
30 million adults now having had two
jabs 90
plus protection against hospitalization
from this delta variant
we've also got a road map that was clear
and linked to the success of that same
vaccination program but against that
backdrop we're being asked to approve a
further delay here today
i spoke to local health leaders in
cumbria and in barrow furnace over the
last few days and the message from them
was clear they support
this delay our director of public health
was stark
because we're trying to cover and back
fill five million
uh people on a nhs waiting list even a
small fraction
of covid patients going into hospital
risk the nhs
being overwhelmed and so on that basis
and on the basis of the rationale put
forward by the secretary of state
i support these measures as one final
push one last heave
before we return our freedoms but we
need to be absolutely
clear about what this delay means
it extends impositions on our liberty
our livelihoods
people's health and the future of young
people and while the state's got a duty
to protect its citizens
our objective can't be zero deaths
with my honorable friend from peniston
and stocksbridge wrote so eloquently
earlier this week
and i apologize for bastardizing her
words we don't live to avoid death
we avoid to enjoy we we live to enjoy
life
and it has to be on that basis that we
make the final judgment to unlock
next month would you allow me on that
point i'm extremely grateful
listen to him very carefully and it is
the good argument for voting for these
restrictions of course it is
but what i just can i just say to him
has he considered the possibility that
the nhs very sadly now is going to be
under pressure for years dealing with
this backlog
my friend makes a a very good point i'm
making the uh the judgment based on
my own local knowledge and and that of
my director of public health
uh but we all have to make that decision
in this place today
we can't afford for schools to close
again for young people to miss any more
of their lives
or for any of our businesses to close as
a result of further impositions
so it has to be one more heave to
protect more people
and then we've got to accept that in the
face of a virus that we are not going to
get rid of and will continue to mutate
and challenge us
whilst we're on this earth we've got to
vaccinate as many people as possible
and then give people back their freedom
because there's a more fundamental issue
at play here which is public acceptance
we made a delicate compact with people
over the last year we restricted their
liberties to keep them safe
and already we're seeing compliance with
that law beginning to fray
we must accept that people expected
their liberty to return as vaccinations
were rolled out but as we vaccinate more
acceptance of that compromise falls
we can't if we can't maintain that
compact then our response to it has to
change
so i hope and expect with this final
surge of vaccinations when we return on
the 19th of july
to a society where people be able to
make their own choices it's easy to
sloganize about freedom
i found them deeply uncomfortable about
living in a country where we dictate to
newly married couples whether they can
cut
their wedding cake or not i believe this
government has acted honorably and with
good intention throughout this horrible
pandemic
so mr deputy speaker i'm giving it my
support tonight for one last heave to
finish the job
and then we must return all of our
freedoms on the 19th of july
this point of order peter bone one of
this different speakers would help me
in regard to social distancing there is
not a single
labor member on the opposition benches
there's no
smp there's no liberal democrats there's
no pride coming
of course they're the dup would it be
appropriate because these benches are
packed for half of half of us to move
over there to improve social differences
well i i think uh peter
uh bone if you have a look around even
on the conservative benches there are a
few green ticks there so i think uh
please stay where you are
jim shannon trigger i'd be very happy
for the album member to come over here
and join us in this on our side where we
are here if he was to do so i know we're
together and many many things in a way
can i just say i i do believe that we
have to live with covert 19
and the same as i get a flu job every uh
september october of every year because
i'm i'm a diabetic and that's where it
is
same way we'll get a covered 19 job come
that time as well
and it's been a very very long hard road
to recovery and i i think i want to put
on record very clearly my
my thanks to government uh and and to
the health minister matt hancock
uh and and and indeed to my own uh
health minister northern robin swan for
all that they have done
to keep us safe over this last period of
time was very very important to put that
on record
i understand that the weddings are
assuming an issue for money and they
certainly are for me and for mike and
sickness as well in the hospitality
sector
uh the wedding attendance is allocated
via the risk assessment of the same
venue
self distancing is to be uh absolutely
critical to make that happen
and and there are so many red and many
venues that can increase their numbers
and have extra numbers there
uh because of the of the distance they
they can have when it comes to
self-discipline
weddings are the most significant day
for couples and there's nothing more
heartwarming
than seeing your guests smile with joy
and the self-destination has made that
happen
um can i make a plea to the minister for
for churches
uh i i do it because i'm a regular
church of tender uh but i do it for
everybody else
who also attends church and would like
to do so um
we know that we have the self distance
in church we do know we have to wear a
mask in church
and we understand that but i'm just
wondering are we getting to the stage
minister
where perhaps maybe a little bit of
stage where we can church we don't have
to wear a mask
again i ask it as a question uh is it
possible
if we're adhering to the the social
disney person when you go to a
restaurant and you don't have to wear a
mask it seems
a wee bit perhaps maybe for churches at
the same rule should apply and i would
request
easement for uh for the weddings and
churches as well
again not every church would have the
capacity of yourself does something
i understand to have a wedding but there
are many who would uh
and and i believe that there's a way
forward a safety to do that
um i um tourism is a crucial sector for
our economy where again the restrictions
are blurred
and many are left confused and i just
make this this request again the
government
the issue with test and passenger
locator forms are discouraging people
from
booking holidays uh not to mention that
portugal was taken off the green nest
i i i don't see it as a criticism to the
minister
but i just make the point and maybe we
need more clarity and releasing that
and and the focus needs to be on making
travel more accessible and efficient
to encourage those to travel even if it
is within the united kingdom
um a consent of miners really therefore
work in the eu where his charge 85 pound
for a pcr test
not to mention the test requirements for
when he comes home
could i ask the minister again uh if
it's possible to review this approach
online lateral flow tests that are
acceptable in our schools to be
acceptable for trauma
travelers i make the point for the um i
believe this is still more efficient
travel where travelers can save money
and travel with less hassle i make a
point as well um mr deputy speaker for
for those who who are are your tour
operators
um and and the buses we know all the
problems for the buses they can't help
dustin's in the bus
and then be a be available uh but but is
there and i know
a plea uh that if we're gonna have it
for another few weeks which we are
um i believe that'll be the intention of
us here
that we can make sure that those
businesses are protected and the jobs
are secured
i also mr deputy speaker and and
short time left uh make a play for live
music
uh for the live music for which i
believe is crucial to many aspects of
life in
itself for us personally but also for
for the venues for the hospitality
sectors for weddings for
for concerts i appreciate there's always
a risk of singing
i know when i sing mr w speaker or
modern deputy speaker
the rain usually comes on i think the
the bible verse says a bit
about sing uh make a joyful noise when i
make the joyful noise it's never
melodious but it's always joyful
it's always right as well i would love
to be able to sing in church again
it hasn't happened it's not likely to
happen in the near future but i
understand for those who
who are uh involved in live music
there's a real need to have that
so over the next four weeks i i just
make the play
uh for for businesses to ensure as we
move forward and move forward together
uh that we can ensure and that those
businesses can be protected
and and that they can ensure that they
have the the support that is needed for
through the fertile i understand that
actually roll right as a part
of any moving forward and i support that
and i welcome young people getting their
backs down
and to me this signal's been able to
move forward uh safely
and this is what we need to do so i
fully support and fully appreciate
the prime minister and government uh are
being careful and cautious to use
a saying that we use in northern dolphin
it is better to be safe than sorry and
it is the better to be safe than sorry
today
so i i will be supporting uh government
and what they're putting forward and
both the the votes that they come
forward
because i believe it's right i believe
that we can do it for another four weeks
you know some
and we get to the end of that and the
vaccine there's more there's more people
in vaccine
and and and confidence will be restored
and if the confidence is restored
then i believe we must all be in a
better place i i know that's not the
opinion of some
but it's a part certainly in my opinion
and the part and the opinion of some
others and my party as well so i want to
ensure that governments support it
and we'll be so i'd be supporting you
tonight as well thank you
i want to discuss two sides of the
science both science is the liberator
and science as the captor we've seen
through this process new vaccines have
been created
using messenger rna completely new type
that will serve us well i'm sure
globally into the future we've
created and rapidly tested them rapidly
rolled them out and that is all to the
the real good we've repurposed existing
drugs such as
the steroid very cheap steroid
dexamethasone we've uh used antivirals
that were used before rem deserve being
just one
and we've discovered new treatments like
monoclonal antibodies
we've created a testing regime that able
that enables us to rapidly test vast
numbers of the population for their
covert status now these
were the new tools that i'd hoped would
prove science as the liberator
and the results were extremely good
let's look at those facts again we've
heard them many times but i think
they're worth putting on the record once
more
with just one dose of any of these
vaccines protection's good with two
doses
it's truly exceptional at over 90
percent protection
against hospitalization even those that
do
find themselves in hospital after
vaccination are generally
not finding themselves dreadfully unwill
unwell
so we've seen hospitalizations reduced
we've got less than a thousand people in
hospital or
a thousand thereabouts just one percent
of nhs capacity
and i'm sure ministers would respond to
that saying that's the way they want to
keep it
uh but i'm afraid the argument will
never end
we've got a death rate of about 10
deaths per day out of a background death
rate in the country
of 1100 per day currently under the
usual average
but let's look at those 10 deaths within
28 days of a positive covet test
their husbands their wives their
brothers their sisters
their parents their friends each
is a tragedy each the family loss each
is a dreadful event but
surely with such low levels
we should now be provided with the data
as to
why what were the deeper underlying
reasons behind those deaths
and i certainly hope ministers have been
provided with that information
because there's a world of difference
and a difference of interpretation that
this place would make
between the death of a young fit person
and somebody
with comorbidity morbid morbidities
perhaps in a hospice with
life-threatening conditions
let's examine science as a captor our
ability to sequence the genome is
incredible
the uk is a world leader hundreds of
variants have been discovered and
doubtless once the delta variant has
passed through just as the alpha kent
variant has been and gone
we'll discover more will it be a
californian one or buenos aires one the
epsilon the zeta and i'm sure
will simply run out of greek alphabet
before and over the coming months
but each one causes hysteria the media
go berserk
the scientists are like having the uh
you know the
the decorator in your house you get
sucking of teeth shaking of head and you
know there's bad news around the corner
we've seen modeling the five key
modelers have come up with
a road map published in february that
the government
understood and and led to the road map
we're on but every one of our figures
are better than that
and that makes this saturn instrument so
unintelligible i would rather trust the
people
what if we were to go for freedom on the
21st of june what would i do because i
think i'm just pretty
normal would i be throwing away my mask
in the supermarket
i very much doubt it i carry
the sterilizing gel in my pocket and i
can say to you madam deputy speaker that
more alcohol goes through my hands on a
daily basis
than a night out with george best and
oliver reed
would that stop no it won't the public
outside of this bubble
have already moved on they've broadly
given up on these petty fogging
rules we should trust the public
and i will not be supporting the
government this evening
disagree thank you madam deputy speaker
the government asserts that it does not
have a zero
covert policy or a zero curve strategy
well
if i accept that that is the case it
does seem as though it's a
0.1 curve strategy it's almost
zero but not quite um
and it the government also at the same
time accepts
uh that the disease is endemic and this
is a very
curious position uh where it's endemic
but
the government is still trying to get
the disease as close to zero
as possible which i would suggest
requires
uh pretty robust action from the
government for the long term
now the original uh lockdown was to
flatten the curve and protect the
national health service
and even though the nightingale
hospitals were soon mothballed and then
closed
that was not enough lockdown was then
intended to enable test track trace
and isolate to get up to speed and it
must surely be there now
but again that was not enough uh then it
was to
vaccinate the most vulnerable the over
50s or the most failed in our society
this is when the narrative was that the
first dose would provide
the vast majority of the protection
required
uh far better than the influenza uh
jab and that the second jab at that
point was only really to give a
longevity
uh to the resistance to covert
that would be required now this should
have
and the expectation was that at that
stage
this would cut the overwhelming majority
of deaths and hospitalizations
and this is the case but still that was
not enough
then it was to have everyone then given
the second dose that's almost been
achieved but as the secretary of state
announced
a short while ago the rollout of
vaccinations now is intended for
21 year olds they can now sign up to get
the vaccine
and again this seems not to be enough
now in bolton we've been through a very
difficult time there's been an amazing
amount of
good work hard work from so many locally
but with this new indian variant or
variant of concern
we coped and the impact on our health
service was far
less than the peak in january
earlier this year the nhs
held up and i believe it's quite clear
now that the link between transmission
hospitalization and death has been
severed
and again this is not enough to find our
lockdown terminus the narrative in
recent weeks seems to have
shifted from initially being about
dealing with the
indian variant and seeing how risky and
dangerous that was to the country
i think the evidence that's available at
the moment shows
we can cope with it
but the position seems to be shifted
from dealing with the indian variant and
trying to understand it to
now offering every adult 18
and over the first dose as
night follows day this will still not be
enough
uh this health secretary has been
downplaying to some extent earlier this
week the value of the first
dose and promoting the value of the
second dose so so should we now be
anticipating a shift
later in the year for every adult to be
offered
that second dose as well that takes us
well into september
perhaps a little beyond we can see the
rolling the pitch for child vaccinations
compulsory vaccination of certain
co-workers and perhaps
others the rolling of the pitch for
i'll give way to my horrible friend
honourable friend
and neighbor in greater manchester could
he reflect briefly for the house and his
experience
in bolton and the declining case rates
girlfriend for raising this important
point transmission in bolton
is clearly on the way down this
demonstrates
the actions taken and the effect and
impact
of this particular variance of concern
which had more impact
in bolton than almost anywhere else in
the country
it's on the way down this should give
reassurance to the country
that we can cope without a further
extension
uh to these measures which are having
such an impact on so many people we just
think
for example about the five million
waiting list for hospital
treatment which would be far longer if
people had better access
to gps to get those referrals so when i
ultimately
think about what's going on i was going
to mention as well the g7 is suggesting
a global vaccine program as well would
we have to wait
until that's being delivered because
until everyone is safe
no one is safe so when the prime
minister refers to a
terminus i fear he doesn't mean the end
i fear he's
thinking more of a boss terminus where
we end one journey
to start another and there'll be another
vehicle
to impose another lockdown extension
speaker and when i have confronted these
votes over the last nine months i have
done my best to look at
the entire health needs and the entire
health case
of all of the nation not just those that
unfortunately have been struck down
with covid so last year when it came to
the 10 pm curfew i looked at that and
felt it didn't
make sense from a health perspective to
see everyone leaving the pub at the same
time
and so i voted against that but when it
came to the decisions towards the end of
last year and into january
i could see the hospitalization cases i
could see the need to get the vaccine
rolled out
and so i supported the government so
where are we
now well let's look at the
hospitalization cases we were at a level
of 35 000
uh covered in patients clearly the nhs
struggling uh to cope
when the um academics at imperial
college
modeled what freedom day being the fifth
of july as they modeled it would look
like in terms of hospital numbers
uh they came up with a figure of seven
thousand warwick university came up with
seventeen hundred and fifty
the figures of coveted inpatients are
currently under
one thousand so better than expected in
my
in the combined county of sussex with
1.6 million
residents there are six coveted
inpatients
in my own county of east sussex there
are two from those six
and interestingly they didn't present
with kobe they didn't get admitted
because of covid they just got
tested whilst they were being admitted
and were found to have covered them
included in the numbers
so the hospitalization numbers are
looking much better
the nhs now has the resilience
but what is striking to me madam deputy
speaker
are the numbers of people who are
waiting to have their lives
enhanced by elective treatment five
million people in england alone
are waiting for surgery over four
hundred
000 of those have been waiting over a
year
prior to covid that figure was 1600
so that demonstrates what restrictions
do to the wider health
impact on people those people deserve a
life too
they deserve to be looked after there
shouldn't be an apartheid system
when it comes to our health service and
what about the vaccine
what a great success we should be
basking in the vaccine
dividend that this government has
delivered in my constituency
east sussex as a whole of the cohorts
one to nine which we know a 99
of the mortality we have 85 percent
double dosed and we know that that
vaccine is effective against
all known strains so we are there
but the difficulty is that we are not
willing to confront
the concept of living with covid
ministers say that we have to live with
kovid
and yet we're given another month on top
and the arguments the ministers use
as to why we need that extra month will
still be there
in a month's time and at that point
we're going to have to decide
where we are going to jump and i spoke
to one of the
very senior nhs leads who has university
aged children and he
said to me and i wrote it down too many
of us making decisions
have forgotten what it feels like to be
a 20 year old or how miserable
it is to be a 20 year old right now
those lives of young people have made
great sacrifices
to help the cohort one to nine that i
talked about
they have made those sacrifices they
need to see a return
they need to see the return this summer
and whilst ministers may say
there are just a few restrictions
remaining we will not start tackling
the backlog in nhs waiting times on
election surgery we will not
start tackling the mental health crisis
and
particularly in young people is being
suffered with such great
detriment we need to tell the country
that we've turned the corner
thanks to them thanks to this vaccine
dividend and we're now ready to accept
the risk
and move on it's about everyone's lives
not just certain lives
pleasure to follow my honourable friend
from bexhill and battle
unlike him i have followed the journey
of sometimes voting with the government
on these restrictions and sometimes
voting against it's unusual mandate
speaker to be after
so you agree with the previous speaker
because the previous speaker is nearly
always from the opposition benches but
of the 51 speakers today man
deputy speaker in this debate only five
are labour back benchers outrageous
and this madam deputy speaker is one of
the most important
debates it is about the freedom and
liberty
of the british people now
of course do you not find it rather odd
that not only is there an absence of
members on
from the opposition but in fact these
restrictions and the government those
are only comfortable getting these
restrictions through because
they have the support the comfort
support of the labour party and yet most
of the speakers from labour party who
have spoken here today
have condemned the the the the
government for attacks
i couldn't agree more more with my can i
say my honourable friend from
across the the aisle and he of course
has been here
for the whole debate but this is about
the liberty of the british people
we're taking away what is our right
so for instance i'm due to go to a
to a wedding but i can't have a group of
friends around my house
beforehand because there'll be too many
when i get to church i can't sing
i can't sing anyway but i'm not allowed
to sing um
then i can't dance at the wedding you
can't dance
and i can't dance either but more
importantly
as the evening drags out i can't then go
to a nightclub
to boogie the night away in celebration
and then the following day i can't go
for a part run
to run all these problems off so i might
need to call a doctor
but i can't go and see a doctor because
he won't do face-to-face
appointments it is withdrawing our very
liberty
now i'm a great fan
as a prime minister and i think most on
these benches
are he came to he came to lead the
conservative party at the
end of the berko parliament when
parliament was in chaos
he took us through a general election he
won a mandate
he delivered brexit he dealt with the
awful
kobe pandemic he led
the world with the vaccine program
and yet tonight unfortunately
i can't support him because
i think every member has to put the
country first
the constituency second and their party
third now as you will appreciate madame
deputy speaker
in my opinion on very many most
occasions
all those three are in line but this
time i don't think the government
has made the case for putting off
unlocking now with apologies to mark
twain
there are lies damn lies and coveted
statistics and the government has been
using an extraordinary propaganda
machine to take certain statistics to
try and prove the case
but if you look at other statistics as
mentioned already
the total number of deaths at the moment
are running below
the five year average as my as the
previous
member said he has very few cases in his
area
in north hamptonshire thankfully in our
two hospitals
we have zero covered patients
and we haven't had a death for five
weeks because of cobit
and the government's own original
forecast for what would happen on may
the 17th
when we did the major unlocking
but their forecast we have done better
than their best prediction of the
situation
so why now have we gone into this
doom and gloom and i i have no doubt
maddie
madame deputy speaker if we were in
opposition our benches would be packed
yeah and there'll sort of be a a blonde
guy
fairly chubby and a bit well as scruffy
as me jumping up and down
and making the case why we should get
rid of
these restrictions i know it's a balance
and i know
people have to make a choice
but we as conservatives believe in
personal responsibility
and common sense and if i actually went
back to my original example
of course i wouldn't go into a busy
nightclub
of course i wouldn't have a hundred
friends around
but that would be my decision not the
decision
of the state so unfortunately
tonight as much as i like the prime
minister
i think it's got he's got it wrong and
i'm going to vote against
mark harper deputy speaker can i uh just
draw attention to my
entry in the register of members
interests as chair of the covid
recovery group and before i turn to the
matters before us
um madame deputy i'd like to put on
record
my thoughts about the loss of joe cox
five years ago i remember
sadly that day very well and you and i
were both in different roles at that
time and it was
our joint responsibility as my case the
government chief whip and yours as the
opposition chief whip to ensure that
this house
was able to be recalled and for
appropriate tributes to be paid
to joe cox and her memory and i know
you're
in your position unable to to speak
often in the house
but i was a great pleasure working with
you on a very sad occasion to make sure
that there was a fitting tribute
paid and i remember that day sadly
very well on a happier note in one sense
i'd like to also put on record my thanks
to sirois stone
for his 44 years of service in the civil
service
which will shortly come to an end
although i'm told he's not retiring
he's going to turn his attention to
other things he was a fantastic
principal private secretary to me when i
was government chief whip and i know his
loss will be felt
across government turning um madam
deputy speaker
of course can i just take this moment
i'm deputy speaker to put on record my
apologies to my writingable friend who
was chief whip through a period where i
was
leading various rebellions and also to
say a great apology to roy stone who
will also
have had to put up with the trouble that
i caused my right angle friend
i'm very grateful for the things that he
said well my
my honourable friend um reminds us all
um
madam deputy speaker how sometimes we
can have different roles
in this house and it's worth just noting
that um
as a former government chief whip i
don't find
not supporting the government a
particularly uh comfortable place to be
but as my honourable friend the member
for wellingborough said sometimes
uh you have to put your what you believe
to be the interests of your country
first
and that's what i feel i'm uh doing i'm
just drawing attention to what my
honourable friend from bolton said
um he's right there are documents in
government i'm not saying these have
been agreed by ministers but it's
certainly advice being given to
ministers
that government should aim to have a
very low prevalence
of kovid which isn't zero covered but
it's not a great distance away now if
ministers were to agree to that strategy
it would mean restrictions going on for
the foreseeable future
and that's one of the things that we're
very concerned about
but i want to focus my remarks um madam
deputy speaker and i do
note at this point again what my animal
friend said the labour benches are
somewhat
empty the back benches are completely
empty and these are it is
colleagues on this side of the house who
are holding the government to account
which i accept the government may
occasionally find uncomfortable but but
it is our role as members of parliament
i always find it helpful to draw
attention to the documents actually
before us
and we have uh for those that don't know
an explanatory memorandum which explains
what it is we're voting on today
this will has been prepared by the
department of health and social care it
will have been approved
by a minister of the crown and it's very
clear it's worth reading
7.3 bullet 2 makes it clear
that the government will likely be able
to offer a first dose of vaccine to all
adults
by july but the vaccinations themselves
will probably not take place until
august due to supply constraints and of
course we know it takes two or three
weeks until those vaccinations are
affected so actually
those adults won't actually be protected
until later in august
so that means this delay is therefore
pointless or alternatively
we're not going to be ceasing these
restrictions
on the 19th of july if vaccinating all
adults
is the goal um if you then turn to
the review date and whether this is
indeed a terminus
that 7.4 7.5 7.6
and 7.7 are very interesting there's a
review
required by the secretary of state every
35 days the first review according to
this isn't due until monday the 19th of
july
no mention here of an early review after
two weeks the first review due by monday
the 19th of july
england it says will remain at step
three for a further four weeks
subject to a further review and it also
says that the purpose of extending these
regulations
the primary purpose is to gather more
evidence
that the tests can be met not that
these rules will expire after four weeks
never to be reintroduced it's to gather
evidence
for tests to be met and then a decision
to be taken about whether these
restrictions are to continue the second
reason given is to allow more people to
receive a vaccination further reducing
the risk which ministers have said
but as i've previously just pointed out
the first doses are not going to be
delivered until august
so that makes no sense something doesn't
add up here
and it's because we're concerned that
these regulations are not going to end
on the 19th of july of course
um i'd like to thank my roger for giving
away
woody uh in the context of timetables
and how things are going to pan out in
the near future
now it's the government's intention to
ensure the vaccination of a
very large number of co-workers which
this is going to take legislation
presumably
it's going to take a period of time for
them to have the vaccination perhaps a
second vaccination
and to deal with all the problems if
this is a requirement for the government
to
be able to deliver a kind of exit from
lockdown
how long will that take it makes a very
good point
and it's it's part of the reason why
we're concerned if this was genuinely
going to the end of it
that would be one thing and i've
listened carefully to the members that
have spoken a number have said
that they will support the government on
this occasion
but this is it and i'm afraid we have
heard that before
and it has turned out not to be true and
i'm afraid just reading the documents in
front of us
that is why um i have some skepticism
the final thing i would say is just for
and i hope that the minister that's
winding up the debate will have a great
deal of respectful can clarify this
i'm not quite sure about what's going to
happen at the end here because
the review of the evidence that's been
gathered
about whether the testimony isn't due to
be
done until the 19th of july so i'm not
clear about
when ministers are going to come to
parliament to set out whether those four
tests have been met
is it going to be on the 19th of july or
is it going to be
before the 19th of july i'm not clear
whether they're going to give that one
week's notice all the way through the
roadmap so far we've had four weeks then
a week's notice so i'm not quite clear
about the timetable it's important
because
as has been said in the debate people's
lives will now be reoriented around that
new date
weddings family events
people's plans and it's important that
our constituents know
what it is that they're going to expect
when can they expect a decision
when can they expect to know what their
life is going to look like
and it's because of those concerns madam
deputy speaker
concerns about whether these regulations
really are the end that i
will i'm afraid be voting against them
this evening and my final point is the
motion
about proceedings in this house it is my
strong view that parliament whilst it's
been welcomed that we've been able to
have parliament meet
through a pandemic and thanks should go
to all of the parliamentary staff
that have made that possible it is i
think
indisputable that this parliament in its
current form
is not as effective in holding the
government to account and enabling us to
do
our job as parliament should be
and i think we should get back to as far
as normal as possible in this house
as fast as we can and it's for that
reason i will also
be voting against the motion to continue
these proceedings effectively
until we return in september
and first of all i would like to thank
the
writer or the gentleman for his kind
words about how
closely we worked uh together
after the tragic murder of uh joe cox
i much appreciated the work that we did
together at that terrible time
um and i'd also like to echo his words
about sir roy stone who i
saw this afternoon to say how much i had
always valued the advice he gave to me
when i was
opposition chief with we now go to sir
john redwood
it is time to trust people more
it is time to control people less
i would like to praise ministers and
officials and particularly all those
scientists medics and researchers
who have worked so hard to make sure
that the uk
is a leader in vaccines supplying one of
the
best vaccines to the world getting it
out early and making it available for
all of us
making sure that we had bought in other
vaccines that became available
so that we're in a position to protect
our population
well and relatively early compared with
other countries
and i pay tribute to all the work that
has gone on by the nhs
and the medics to understand how to
treat the disease better
how it is transmitted so that we can
take better actions
to give people greater security so i say
now
to all these experts the nhs the
government share what is relevant
with the rest of us the public and let
us make more of our own risk assessments
because we are now saying to people that
there are two major ways
in which we can all protect ourselves
against the possibility of getting this
or getting a bad version
we're making two jobs available to all
adults who want them
and the figures so far show that that
gives you
a much better probability of not
catching the disease at all
and it gives you very strong protection
against a serious case of the disease
which is
what we're mainly worried about because
we're trying to stop people dying we're
trying to stop people
struggling in intensive care we're
trying to stop that pressure on the nhs
and all the
suffering that it produces but we're
also saying to people
if you're still worried about residual
risks or if you really
don't like vaccines you yourself can
self-isolate and i hope the government
will continue
as an employer and as the government
guiding others in the economy
to say that we should be generous and
supportive of anyone who really does
feel they need to protect themselves
against the virus by self-isolation but
i think we're now well beyond the stage
where we have to isolate practically
everybody else to some extent
when so many people now have protection
and so many people are making their own
risk judgments
want to get on with their lives in that
room when assessing the data it's most
important
that we look at all the data about jobs
livelihoods incomes
family stress mental health pressures
because this is creating all of those so
i think the government can do more but i
think what the government should be
doing
is it should be helping the private
sector to manage air flows and air
extraction and ultraviolet cleaning and
so forth to make it safer
for many more social contact businesses
to reopen and have a reasonable number
of people
enjoying their services i think more
could be done
on making sure that all our health
settings
have really great infection controls we
don't want any more slippages
from health settings themselves i would
urge the government to think again
about an idea they looked at early on
but then didn't develop
which is why in the large populated
areas particularly the big connervations
we can't have a an isolation hospital
that deals with covered and other very
infectious diseases
well away from the general hospital
because i think you add to the pressures
and likelihood of
infection if you have a general hospital
taking in
a very infectious disease but i do think
now there is huge scope to get a really
good economic recovery to save some jobs
to create some new jobs to get
paid up to have many more transactions
in the economy
but to do that we need to relax and we
need to trust the people more
i think my constituents are ready to
make decisions about their own lives
again
many are very frustrated they're not
allowed to
we have all this great advice we have
all this great knowledge let's not get
too gloomy
and let's not lock everybody up again
um as colleagues will be aware there
have been quite a few interventions
so um i after the next speaker
i would i will have to take the time
limit down to three minutes in order to
get everybody
in gareth bacon and thank you madam
deputy speaker i will be
supporting the government this evening
but on this occasion my support is
heavily qualified
like many of my constituents i'm
disappointed that stage four of the
government's roadmap for reopening has
been pushed back
to the 19th of july but like i believe
the majority of them i understand the
reasoning for the four-week delay the
government have consistently stated
that the roadmap marks the 21st of june
as the earliest opportunity
to end restrictions not a date set in
stone but it's clear
that the delta variant has changed the
race between the virus
and the vaccine if we only face the
alpha variant
then the extraordinary level of first
doses the nhs has delivered would
undoubtedly have been enough
for us to be fully reopening next week
but two jabs are needed for the highest
level of protection against the dominant
delta variant
understandably i believe this means that
the nhs needs more time
to fully vaccinate more people before
ending restrictions
however i do share concerns that one
more short delay may in fact lead to
many more
there is a risk at the government's
decision-making process of becoming too
cautious
in the face of the next wave of
coronavirus
if that happens we may miss our chance
to fully reopen in the summer
before the trickier autumn and winter
months
while i believe my constituents can
stomach a short delay the government
must provide assurances that this delay
will be the final hurdle coronavirus is
not going anywhere
we will have to learn to live with it
and the risk it poses to public health
just like we do
with the flu the government must hold
its nerve and let the vaccines do their
job
it shouldn't be afraid of its own
success the nhs vaccination program has
been
a resounding triumph in my own
constituency of orphans so nearly 100
000 people have been vaccinated
thanks to the tremendous effort of the
local nhs staff
and volunteers almost 60 000 of these
jobs have been administered in the
orpington health
and wellbeing center which marked six
months as a vaccination center
this week data shows clearly
that the vaccines that we have available
are successful in combating
all known variations of the virus
as these vaccine numbers continue to
increase it will therefore be impossible
to explain any further delay this delay
has serious economic ramifications
especially for small businesses for
example the 100
business rate relief for retail
hospitality and the leisure sector
is due to end on the 30th of june
employer contribution changes to the
cjrs are due to take effect
on the first of july many businesses
that are unable to fully reopen
are now faced with paying bounce-back
loans
the government therefore needs to set
out what support businesses can expect
as a result of this delay and we also
need to know
what proportion of people need to be
vaccinated to sever the ties
between cases and hospitalizations how
many more adults therefore
need to be fully vaccinated and the
government's plan to deliver these
vaccines in time
so that we can reopen on the 19th of
july
if the government can provide this
detail it will go a long way to calm
worries
that restrictions will go on and on and
never be lifted
that's why i hope the government will
now set out in detail what needs to
happen in the next five weeks
so that we can finally and fully reopen
on the 19th of july
as being noted by my colleagues there
are very few labour backbenchers taking
part in this debate
particularly the point made by my
honourable friend for wedding bro now
their labor colleagues are not bad
people they're not lazy
but they're not interested in as we are
in freedom
and this whole debate is a mortal threat
is a mortal threat to the conservative
party and this is proven by history
when we had a wartime regulation
controlled economy
uh between 1939 and 1945 it led to a
labor landslide people get used to
controls
and at the end of july and this is going
to go through today obviously by the end
of july there must be an entire reset of
the conservative government
we must be talking about freedom civil
liberties
trusting business not subsidizing
business that is what
low taxes that is what the conservative
party is about
let's look at the data in lincolnshire
uh
sadly we've had one death but only one
death in the last month
we've got a population of 651 000 adults
504 000 have had their first job of
those 400 thousands have had their
second jab
95 of over 70s have had two jabs 75
percent of over 50s in lincolnshire
have had two jabs there's no reason for
lincolnshire to be under any
restrictions at all but i accept that we
are
one country but i'm i don't know why
if we have to have controls we can't
have regionalized
controls the government must
act according to reasonable
proportionality our job
as backbenchers is to scrutinize the
executive
but how can we scrutinize the executive
we don't know what the goal of the
executive is
there's been too much shifting of
goalposts too many factors rules
based not on science but on populism
our society should be free and open and
there's a real danger the public would
increasingly ignore this the government
will be a government of the emperor
without clothes
of course the public in large part
support these further controls but what
about business
business is being driven into the ground
and you don't support business as by
endless subsidies
you let business get on with business
and this is never going to end
at the end of this month there'll be
another variant it'll be
come from you know darkest peru the
peruvian variant and patent and bear
will be arrested in paddington station
because there's a risk of
putting quarantine it'll go on and on
and on
it's a bit of a cliche now but the fact
is we're never going to eradicate this
disease it's like no other disease
it's going to constantly vary it's going
to constantly
attack us we just have to learn
to live with it and we have to base our
policy not
on the number of infections which will
rise and fall and probably keep rising
with every new variant our policy
is to save the nhs our policy
is to protect the nhs to stop the nhs
falling over
there's only one policy that makes sense
at the end of july
and that is if the nhs is in danger and
if hospitals
are in danger of becoming over full that
should be our policy
happy sussex day madam deputy uh speaker
and like every good horny handled son
and daughter of sussex i'm afraid i
won't be drove into the government
uh lobby uh this evening deputy speaker
hashtag
i'm done that was the overwhelming
message on social media on monday when
independence day
so tantalizingly close was cruelly
whipped away from our constituents again
so madame deputy speaker i'm done with
making excuses to my constituents for
when their lives
might just get back to some degree of
normality we are constantly told it is
about data not dates
quite right well we have the imminent
dates by which the vaccination program
will have achieved effective herd
immunity well ahead of what was imagined
when the lockdown route map was designed
now 80 percent
of adults having had their first days
we've had the data showing that the fisa
vaccine is 96
effective against the delta variant
after two doses and the astrazeneca won
92 we have the data showing an average
of nine deaths a day at the moment at
1136 hospitalizations a world away from
where we were at the start of the
roadmap
we've had the data from public health
england that only three percent of delta
varying cases
had received two vaccinations and we
also had the dodgy data from three
modeling studies from the university of
warwick imperial college
and the london school of hygiene and
tropical medicine showing widely
different scenarios with the most
pessimistic warning
that the uk could experience a further
203
000 deaths by next june around 50 000
more than the first and second ways
combined yet how can that be
when we know the vaccine works and data
shows
a likely 90 percent take-up rate
yet it is these doomsday models by
largely anonymous
wonks with no remit for considering the
impact of further broker lockdown
on life at large that seem to trump all
the other data
and the government puts them on a
pedestal above all others they are
confusing modelling for scientific
forecasts
i would be delighted
is my honourable friend saying really
that the scientists are just
concentrating on one thing and ignoring
everything else well the trouble is
there are lots of different scientists
and they don't agree with each other and
it's only certain scientists who seem to
have an impact on the government and it
usually is the most doomsday of those
scenarios so
where is the data that shows allowing
six people inside a pub
has increased infection rates and by how
much where is the data that shows how
much faster the infection
has spread because up to 30 people have
been able to meet outside
since the original journey out of
lockdown where's the data showing that
the nhs
is being overwhelmed not by covid
patients but by a huge increase in
children and families suffering mental
illness
including many worrying episodes that
we've seen as constituency mps
or by the surge in advanced cancer cases
that could not be diagnosed and treated
early
where's the data showing how many
businesses particularly in the
hospitality sector
cannot wait a further four weeks to be
profitable and will likely now fail with
the accompanying impact on people's jobs
and livelihoods
and where being and well where is the
data showing the impact on the
well-being of children
now denied sports days for another year
school prom
students again denied graduation
ceremonies for a second year having
missed out on so much of their
university
uh experience and where is the data on
the impact
of domestic abuse that has risen so much
we've seen where's the data showing
the continuing back to on babies the
problem is madame deputy speaker
that the only data considered seems to
exclusively the worst case scenarios
about the spread of covid regardless
of the current single figure average
death rate
no covid strategy is risk-free but a
further delay is by no means a
victimless decision
it's time that we trusted people to live
with covid
just as the prime minister announced in
february in the same way that we live
with flu but we don't let flu get in the
way of living
our lives and the government promised at
that stage that we would move to
personal responsibility
my fear is that the government continued
to try to nully people
they would just not take any notice and
then no amount of retained rules will
make any difference
people are already increasingly making
their own risk assessments
as somebody tweeted the other day i've
had covered
i have antibodies i've had both jabs
i've worn a mask
i've sanitized within an inch of my life
i've done
no more it's over my fear is that this
will become
a much more widely held view if the
government just keep delaying freedom
day
without the evidence to back it up
just to say i really don't mind
interventions taking place
but at this stage we've got 13 people to
get in
um before i start the wind-ups so every
intervention means that somebody is not
going to
get in um and i would urge people
actually to be less than three minutes
if they can
jeremy wright thank you very much madam
deputy speaker i think
in all the difficult judgments the house
has had to make during
the pandemic this is perhaps one of the
most difficult
and i entirely respect the arguments of
those who've spoken already in this
debate and who've come to a different
conclusion
than i have this is of course as ever a
balance of risks in this case between
the delta variant
and the risks of ongoing restrictions
which are not
insignificant and we have to ask
ourselves what's
changed since the last time we looked at
the roadmap and at
its end point the government strategy
has not changed
it remains to vaccinate prioritizing the
most vulnerable
and that cannot require everyone to be
vaccinated that's neither scientifically
necessary
nor practically achievable the
significant change
is what an effective response to the
delta variant now seems to
require that being two doses of vaccine
not
just one and i do see the significance
in that of the difference between the 57
percent of the adult population
with two doses now and the 76
we should reach by the 19th of july and
that argument
allows me just to support the government
tonight
but i want to make two other points the
first
is that the logic of this extension is
to protect the nhs from a significant
increase in hospitalization from covert
19
and this protection comes at a high cost
to the economy
and to the rest of society so we need to
take full
advantage of it and whether that's in
reducing the backlog of treatments for
other medical conditions
or in giving nhs staff a break before
what may be
another difficult winter i think it
would help if ministers can explain what
we are doing
with the time and space this extension
is buying us
and the second point is this i as others
have been
i'm extremely concerned about what
recent decision making
tells us about our collective tolerance
of risk
scientists and ministers alike have told
us that we are going to have to live
with kovid indefinitely
but we don't know what that means if not
the acceptance of ongoing risk of
illness and even death
and we do not understand what tolerable
risk looks like
the roadmap had four stages no more and
if the logic of this extension to the
last stage is to allow greater
vaccination
then when that is achieved we must be
able to say the restrictions
will be lifted so that businesses and
individuals can at long last
start to plan with certainty anything
else will move us
from risk management to risk aversion
and risk aversion has consequences
broader than the management of the
pandemic
appetite for risk for example is a
crucial ingredient of
innovation and invention ironically the
things that have delivered the vaccines
and the progress we've made against
covid so far so despite my reservations
i will support the government tonight
but i want a commitment to use those p
period of extra restrictions
wisely and a firmer commitment to end
restrictions on the 19th of july
thank you madam deputy speaker this
great country is the cradle of freedom
for over eight centuries at least since
the time of magna carta
this mother of parliament has protected
rights and liberties of the british
people
i together with many others in this
place have been deeply troubled by the
temporary restrictions
that we have asked the british people to
observe and the sacrifices
we have asked them to make i have
supported every covid decision to date
with a clear sight
of the need to tackle the virus that was
rampaging through gloucestershire in the
uk
and hospitalizations and covert deaths
were a serious daily threat
my heart continues to go out to
everybody who has lost loved ones
yet madam deputy speaker we are in a
very different situation now and i
cannot support a confused further delay
of the road map in these circumstances
now is the time to trust the british
people we've heard that a lot tonight
we must trust them to continue acting
with the caution and we must trust them
to make choices
to protect the health of their friends
family and loved ones
i am proud of how the people and
businesses of stroud the valley and vale
have supported their neighbours they
have volunteered in their thousands and
put themselves forward for vaccinations
and all to regain their historic
freedoms
to stay well and get back to some form
of normal and in stroud we have 87
of people vaccinated for the first time
of 55 fully vaccinated
thankfully only three people are in
hospital in gloucestershire with covid
and i pray for their swift recovery so
at a time when our hospitals are nowhere
near overwhelmed by covert and we're
told we need to learn to live with the
virus
it's only right that we now look to
protect the others from the impact of
restrictions
to dismiss this delay as only four weeks
is disrespectful
these weeks are crucial for many but not
least for businesses
who invested money and hope in being
able to trade viably next
week those in the hospitality
entertainment weddings
and exercise and the travel sectors for
these summer weeks
they follow a lost summer last year and
they cannot be made up over the ultimate
winter months
being involved in the negotiations for
the wedding industry
has also led me to this position months
of work
evidence gathering and sensible
suggestions were swept aside by health
officials at the last minute
without explanation and against a
backdrop of thousands of people
hugging at the football and the cricket
which i love by the way
why reject testing in sport like we have
in sporting events and then make a
father wear a mask
walking his daughter down the aisle he
will eat a maskless dinner with her
later in that day
what have we come to when the government
is banning dance floors
and i am equally confused by banging
banning singing in churches
our predominantly double-jabbed
congregations just want to sing to god
let them sing
madame deputy speaker these are not easy
decisions the difficulties facing our
government are extraordinary
and i sincerely respect those on both
sides of the house who have different
views
i have the utmost respect for the prime
minister and health secretary and i
don't mind saying out loud
this was a difficult decision but with
the welfare of stroud firmly in my mind
i praise the courage and sacrifice that
the people of this great nation have
shown
and i say that now is the time for us to
trust the people give them their freedom
day
richard thank you madam dr speaker what
on earth is happening to our country
madam deputy speaker
muzzled acquiescent and fearful having
fought and defeated
one project fear i never thought we'd
experience another
sadly unlike the first the polls would
suggest that the majority of the
population
has succumbed to the second armed with
this information
the decision makers feel they can creep
out with their shovels
and move the goalposts at will
personally
i'm not surprised the nation's been
beaten into submission
when day after day hour after hour we
aren't
deluged with dar warnings of doom and
gloom
by government advisers of one kind or
another
a section of the press and media must
take responsibility for their role
in creating this near orwellian
nightmare don't get me wrong
i have never underestimated the threat
this pandemic poses
every death an illness is deeply
regrettable
but surely there comes a time when for
the greater good of the majority
a sense of proportion must be adopted
this is not easy to do when graphs and
statistics are presented to support
this one month extension despite those
far better qualified than i who
questioned their methodology
presentation and even accuracy
so much that was predicted has not come
to pass
madam deputy speaker and the so-called
third wave is not killing
or hospitalizing anywhere near the
numbers affected in wave one or two
why well it's due to this remarkable
vaccine rollout
for which the government the front bench
the nhs must
take huge credit from the initial
promise
of regaining our freedom when the
vulnerable have been inoculated
i can understand the government's
reluctance to give it back
first it's easier to say no and second
let's not forget there's a public
inquiry hanging over
the government like the sword of
damocles the revelations from domnick
cummings and the accusations that
followed them
were no doubt a sobering taster to
ministers of what is to come
however fearing and inquiry and variants
are not
reasons for delaying freedom day
mistakes have been made
that was inevitable given the
unprecedented nature of this pandemic
but that does not mean being risk averse
now
we desperately need a confident
government to take a proportionate stand
in the face of the evidence
for months the government's cry was
protect the nhs
on tuesday the organization's chief
executive said that only one percent of
hospital beds
were occupied by patients we know that
emissions are rising in the northwest
but not on the scale seen in the second
wave
yes totally unlocking is a risk but it's
a proportionate one
when considering the appalling damage
being done to the risk takers
those who create our prosperity and jobs
and they're continuing the successful
rollout
of the vaccines and as for this place
i've been here long enough to know
that when there's agreement across the
majority of the house something is
fundamentally wrong
it's withdrawn so we go straight to
james sunderland
but under speaker over the past few
months i've repeatedly called for an end
to restrictions at the earliest
opportunity and i believe that the
success of our vaccination programme
gives us that opportunity we're all
aware of the pain that's been inflicted
on so many leisure tourism
hospitality aviation that this goes on
this has manifested itself in the loss
of jobs and livelihoods and whilst the
government has done much to mitigate
the fallout through its generous support
schemes it has just scratched the
surface when what people really want to
do is to return to normal
when you walk down the voting lobby it's
never a binary choice
no decision is clear-cut there are bits
of every motion
that you agree with and bits that you
don't like
and for any self-respecting politician
with the best interest of constituency
country and party at heart you just hope
that the stars do align
but i do have mixed feelings about the
extension to the current lockdown rules
on the one hand creating a wall of
immunity
amongst all adult demographics seems
sensible so that we can move forward but
by the same token the ongoing
restrictions in how we live
our lives is killing business and people
all over the uk
not only is the cost the taxpayer
immense but there's also a cost to our
hopes
dreams and mental health and the sooner
we can smash through lockdown the better
however i've also been unequivocal that
any policy decision
needs to be driven by the science and it
remains the fact that the delta variant
is causing
real concern with infections
hospitalizations and
deaths spiking alarmingly aside from all
the disappointment
the pm could not have been clearer in
his stated position at the weekend
and it may just be that our young
generation has an expectation
of being vaccinated against the killer
disease before all restrictions are
lifted
and it may be that cases are growing by
65 percent per week and maybe the
hospitalizations are increasing by 50
per week across the uk and it may be
that the nhs does need and deserve
four more weeks to complete its job
submarine deputy speaker
in the light of the evidence presented
to me and the decisions that have been
made in good faith
i will be supporting all government
motions this evening
i'd like to raise two final points if i
may first it's a central please that
when the list of authorized pilots is
released
that it must include those flagship
global events such as the euros
wimbledon
british grand prix chelsea flower show
and the goodwood festival of speed
the alternative i'm afraid will be
cataclysmic
and lastly i am increasingly concerned
by the dichotomy between
the unprecedented success of our
vaccination program
and the ongoing risk aversion with
government as a military man i am
comfortable
with risk and i feel that we all now
need to live with kovid in a way that's
not been achieved so far
so using military parlance given that we
cannot transfer or terminate
it that lord knows we've tried to treat
it and it's now time to robustly
tolerate kovid i've got a feeling that
all good will
will be exhausted if the government does
not
honor its promise on the 19th of july
thank you
pauline latham not here so we go
straight to miriam cates
thank you madame dr speaker following
the science is an attractive
even comforting idea in a time of
uncertainty
but when i say this as a scientist we
can no more
follow science than we can follow
history science gives us knowledge and
understanding
but it can't give us wisdom and it's
wisdom that we need
to make what are essentially moral and
political decisions
about how we balance the short and
long-term best interests of our whole
society
i'm saddened that we have lost i hope
only temporarily
this sense of balance preventing death
from covid
seems to have become the principal
purpose of our national endeavor
no matter the cost to our way of life
we've placed insufficient emphasis on
the terrible
long-term consequences of lockdown from
poverty unemployment lost education debt
undiagnosed cancer loneliness
hopelessness and fear
and focus far too narrowly on just one
set of metrics
the daily covert data now even the most
hardened libertarian would accept an
international emergency
in the face of significant threat to
life restrictions to our freedoms have
been necessary and right
but with all vulnerable people now
having been offered vaccination
the balance of risk has shifted covet is
no longer a substantial threat
the average covered mortality for june
so far is seven deaths a day
seven out of around 1500 daily deaths
that we could expect
in normal times the number of people in
hospital
now stands at 1177
some 37 000 fewer than at the peak in
january
and thanks to the incredible efficacy of
our vaccination program
it's hard to comprehend how our
hospitals could quickly
become overwhelmed the idea that we are
still in a state of emergency
just isn't supported by the evidence and
yet significant legal restrictions on
our basic freedoms are to remain
even dictating how many of our family
and friends can visit us
in our own private homes the
restrictions we face are now out of
proportion to the threat
and so extending the measures sets a
dangerous precedent
madam deputy speaker we must learn to
live with covet in the way that we live
with so many other risks
vaccines will never be 100 effective
just like seat belts smoke alarms or
contraception
but it's vital to our autonomy and our
identity as human beings
that we're able to make our own choices
and our own evaluations of everyday
risks
as has been the norm in our country for
generations
now i have the greatest respect for
ministers who've had to make
unimaginably difficult decisions over
the last year
but now is the time to restore a sense
of balance
and proportion and fairness and to make
a return
to life in all its fullness and in my
final seconds i want to say this
childhood should be a time that is
carefree
and testing our children twice a week
making them wear masks when they
are not at risk constantly reminding
them that they may be a danger
to people that they love it's damaging
them psychologically and we have to stop
if everybody was now two minutes um
everybody would
get in i'm sure dr kieran mullen will
lead the way
um thank you madame dr speaker i've
listened carefully to the contributions
this afternoon and we've done a good job
i think in articulating the challenge we
face
basically what is reasonable to do to
stop coronavirus spreading infecting and
killing enormous numbers of people and
overwhelming the hs
the answer to that that asks us to
consider what the costs are for doing
something
and what the costs are for doing nothing
there has been a cost of freedom from
lockdowns but freedom is complex
what freedom of people aged over 50
years and up have had to venture out
of their home when coronavirus ran
rampant and left them with at least a 1
in 200 chance or worse of dying that
they caught it
there's been a cost of businesses in
particular hospitality and other
businesses
people have been stopped from visiting
i'm certain that had nhs been
overwhelmed
should one in 200 people age 50 started
dying on mass
should the news have been showing
patients turned away from itu the impact
on those businesses would have been
similar if not the same as locked down
there's been a cost of children's
welfare
which parent would really have carried
on sending their children to school
knowing that there would be no help if
there was an outbreak of meningitis or
media measles
and how traumatized with the nation's
children had been when one in 200 or
more of their grandparents died
in the space of a year or two there's
been a cost to people with illnesses
like cancer from lockdown
where exactly would cancer patients have
gone after their operations when itus
were full
and which immunocompromised patients
having chemo would have risked
visiting their local hospital for
treatment and running the risk of
catching kovid
it's wrong for critics of lockdown to
think they alone care about freedom
hospitality businesses children those
suffering from other illnesses
we all do i do i just took what i
thought was the rational choice in
weighing up the costs across the board
i must take issue with people today
who've talked about our freedoms not
being used to support the nhs is that
some kind of abstract concept
what we're talking about there is
supporting the patients and their
friends and family who have been
prevented from accessing the nhs
if the restrictions have not prevented
the nhs from being overwhelmed
it was always inevitable over time that
these judgments would have become
more finely balanced as they have done
but i'm not going to be told that i'm
not capable of continuing to make these
finally
balanced judgments it's right that the
next phase means a new discussion
like others i found these types of
restrictions restrictions that stop us
living out our fundamental desires to
mix and socialize and spend time with
each other
a heavy heavy price to pay and i have no
doubt that the public will be willing to
pay
a similarly heavy price to remove most
if not all of them
but that's not to say people won't mind
wearing a mask on the tube for example
we have some tough decisions ahead of us
and i welcome the recognition of that
from government and it's now time
that the government states more clearly
and starkly what these choices are for
us so the british public can start to
together
decide together what sacrifices we are
and are not willing to make
thank you madam deputy speaker as mps
were asked to take fundamentally
political
decisions balancing the certainty of
harm done to people's livelihoods and
well-being
that's caused by restrictions with the
imminent risk to people's lives and the
ability of our health services
uh to cope if the pandemic were to
spiral out of control
we can only do so on the basis of the
very best medical and scientific advice
that is available now two weeks ago i
was sure that there was no reason why
step four should not go ahead
on the 21st of june within days that
certainty looked foolish
the advice now is clear that pressing
ahead on monday
would lead to massive increases in
admissions
that would leave our hospitals with more
covered
patients than in the worst points of
last year
and given that and the clear guidance
from our local nhs leaders of the impact
that this would have
on their ability to treat people in need
the only
responsible course of action is to pause
however that does not mean that we
should not question and test
that advice unlike some i do not believe
that the advice is being manipulated to
secure a specific outcome
this is not another 45-minute dossier
but some of the
modelling does look strange some of the
assumptions
could be questionable the effectiveness
of the vaccines
are estimated at 89 and 90 percent in
the modeling whereas public health
england data
puts it at 92 and 96
now the difference between 89 and 96
might not sound huge but if you flip it
around then the difference in
ineffectiveness rate
between 4 and 11 is enormous
and clearly would have significant
policy implications
now the models project two and a half
thousand hospital admissions per day
within eight weeks that suggests a rate
of increase of forty percent per week
much higher than we are currently uh
experiencing
now if that increase was actually thirty
percent then the admissions will be
close to 1400 per day
and if the current rate of 22 we've seen
in the last week was to
continue then it would reach uh just 800
after eight weeks and surely those
differences would lead to different
uh policy choices and that is why this
two-week break
break point is important and why it's
vital that ministers take it seriously
i will back the motions tonight but if
the data over the next two weeks do not
bear out the hypotheses in the models
we must rethink felicity beckham
thank you madam deputy speaker i have
been contacted
by many constituents who are concerned
about the extension of these
restrictions especially when
cases and hospitalizations are still at
a low
absolute level i also represent a
central london constituency
and central london is suffering very
hard as a result of the fact that people
are still encouraged to work at home the
fact that we have
very few international business visitors
and residents and employment
in central london is looking
unemployment
is looking very bad here however
i do acknowledge the fact that clearly
with two shots of the vaccines there is
no question
that there is better resistance to
hospitalization
so i will support government tonight
for one final heave over
the line but i would urge
government to make sure that we
do not lose the benefit of
two vaccines for instance why are we
still encouraging people to work from
home
when they are doubly vaccinated why
are we asking people to quarantine
at home if they have been in contact
with a case
when they are double vaccinated we
really
do need to refine and perfect
all of these features because this is
having
a meaningful impact on people's lives
so i will support the government but
we've got work to do
and we need to get out of these
restrictions
number 43 is withdrawn so we go to aaron
bell
thank you madam deputy speaker i've
supported the government throughout on
corona virus measures
uh but today we've come very close to
the point for me personally that the the
line has been breached and i have
listened to some
very persuasive speeches from colleagues
who have come to that point today
my honourable friend from straub my
honourable friend from stockbridge today
i myself am sticking with the government
on this occasion
for the reasons that the member for
north somerset gave earlier the same
reasons in fact that the health
secretary gave me
in the lobbies earlier the need to get
those second jabs into people who are
still at risk of hospitalization but
my friend from dudley south recently
said
we must take that two-week review
seriously because there is evidence even
today
that we are starting to bend the curve
of exponential growth the ra is starting
to fall on cases in england
we know there is a 10-day lag to
hospitalizations but we've also seen the
hospitalization
percentages falling it was eight percent
of cases turned into hospitalizations in
the autumn
it's down to four percent now if that
continues to drop the case the
government is making
will get weaker and weaker i would like
to briefly pay tribute to the health
secretary
not only for all his work on this his
assiduousness in coming to the house
today
also for helping me in newcastle
underlying with a major public health
issue of a landfill that he's been
incredibly engaged with
i think the health secretary has done a
fantastic job throughout this pandemic
and and and i will and i welcome what
he's what he said today
uh and that he himself obviously has his
reservations
but this is the right decision for the
country uh
at this time and very briefly as i serve
on the procedure committee
uh with with my right honourable friend
the member for staffordshire marlins as
chair she spoke earlier
i will be supporting those motions as
well because as we've said in the
committee
i think it's absolutely fundamental that
we align what we do in this house with
what we're asking the country to do
chris logan thank you madam thank you
madam deputy speaker it's
a pleasure to speak in this debate one
that i know
is of huge importance both to this house
and to the country
madam deputy speaker as the member for
west dorset we have had
one of the lowest numbers of cases and
deaths across the whole country
as it stands today in the whole of
dorset
we have just one person poorly in
hospital
we have not lost anybody from this virus
for around two months it is therefore
with great regret that i have to tell
the government today that i find it
very difficult to support the government
i will not be doing so
in the lobby this evening the
vaccinations
that i think many if not all of us have
received
have been i think a scheme of national
pride
it has brought great reassurance to many
many people
across this country but we now have to
help
everybody in the nation particularly
those who in my constituency where 97
of our businesses are small and micro
sized who are
feeling this so painfully at the moment
we need to be able to give them the
summer as the opportunity to get their
business
back not just for the short term but for
the long term
as well and it is therefore uh madam
deputy speaker why
i as the member for west dorset have to
make it
very clear to the government this
evening that i'm afraid i'm unable to
support
the vote in the lobby thank you
uh we now go to neil o'brien who i've
also asked if he could stick to
two minutes thank you madam deputy
speaker
none of us want these restrictions to go
on for a moment longer than they have to
and all of us are proud of our
world-leading vaccination effort and i
paid tribute
to everyone involved in delivering it in
harborough odby
and wigston but when we see that cases
are doubling roughly every 10 days we
see that within a week or two
we'll be back to the same number of
cases every day that we're at at the
start of the november lockdown
we can see why there is real cause for
concern here
and that is why is right to go for the
delay that we're going to vote for this
evening we know they're getting a second
vaccination dose gives you a lot more
protection against this dangerous
new variant we know that many more
people will be fully vaccinated as a
result
of this delay and that will potentially
save thousands of lives so it's the
right thing
to do my police administers are as
follows the first is that we use this
time that we're buying tonight to really
drive vaccination rates
among that last four percent that lasts
maybe million people among the most
clinically vulnerable groups
as the number of cases accelerates those
people have got a target on their back
and
it would be a tragedy for them to die of
fear or ignorance or simple lack of
knowledge
at this stage at the very end of the
pandemic second my police to minister
is to continue to improve our ability to
detect an early stage
and close our borders against dangerous
strains while the indeed variant is very
dangerous
as this thing bounces around the world
one day there will potentially be
something worse and we need to be ready
for that
and last but not least we must improve
our ability to nip future pandemics in
the bud
and i think that involves reappraising
our attitudes towards things like uh
challenge trials so we never have to go
through this again
uh madam deputy speaker uh the
restrictions that we are going to
delay ending for a few more weeks
tonight
it's the right thing to do it's a
difficult decision it's the right
decision
and we need to do all the things we need
to put in place to make sure that we are
never in this position again and when
we abolish these restrictions we abolish
them forever
thank you uh number 47 is withdrawn so
the final
speaker is sean bailey
you madame deputy speaker and it's
always a little bit trepidatious coming
at this part of the debate
um i think we've i think this has been a
very finely balanced debate this evening
and
the difficulty is after so many uh great
contributions you do feel like you're
repeating yourself a bit
but this is a difficult decision and i
don't envy the position the government
finds themselves in and it is a nuanced
balance that we've got to tread on the
one hand
ensuring that we protect the most
vulnerable on the other hand
safeguarding those liberties that
all of us i think actually on this house
want to ensure that we
and our constituents can enjoy now
the pandemic in my communities in samoa
has been different because we haven't
been able to work from home
the majority of my constituents have had
to go out to work in this pandemic
they've had to be in the factories
they've had to be in the jobs that
require them to be there so
i think the first thing i would say is
to dispel that idea perhaps that at
times this this notion of all we can all
carry on we can all work from home
just doesn't happen i'm afraid it's it's
not um
it's just not reality but i think the
important point that i would say that
has been raised by many honorable right
honourable members
across the house this evening is about
utilizing the time that
we will now have as resources because
this will go through this evening and
ensuring that we plan properly and the
issues
and the the challenges that we're facing
within our nhs and i want to talk
actually particularly if i may madame
deputy speak about primary care
because that is a big thing for my
constituents no more so
at the moment than in my in one of my
communities in tipperdale
where my constituents are struggling to
get to gp appointments i've had one
constituent contact me today
150 times she's had to call the surgery
to try and get
in to see someone it is not acceptable
it cannot carry on
and i've had really positive discussions
with my honourable friend and his team
in the department of health but we've
got to find a solution to this
and it's using this time not just in the
short term but fleshing out that
long-term plan
to deal with these issues going forward
because our nhs has done a fantastic job
during this pandemic
we've now got to ensure that the issues
that we we've seen highlighted that have
come to light as a result of the
situation we find ourselves in
are dealt for the long term so the
legacy of this pandemic madam deputy
speaker
is that we ensure that we pay back those
nhs heroes
who have saved so many people thank you
49 withdrawn so shadow minister justin
mattis
thank you madam deputy speaker can i can
i just start by associating myself with
the
many members who pay tribute to joe cox
today um
as we heard from the tribute so she
transcended intake and partying bringing
people together and
my thoughts are with her family at this
time
in terms of the debate there's been i
think a number of excellent
contributions
on both sides and and people who will be
voting in different ways actually
often made many similar points which i
think shows the disappointment we all
feel that we are
here once again grappling with many
overlapping
uh and multiple considerations and i
think there were some particularly
thought-provoking
uh contributions from from this side of
the chamber from my world friends for
blackley and broughton city of chester
luton north leeds east and stockport and
i
particularly enjoyed my honorable friend
the member for luton north's speech and
her repeated use of the word hopeless
a word i am sure is on many people's
lips at the moment
and she was right that we have been here
before as we were at christmas with a
prime minister dangling the carrot of
freedom before pulling away at the last
minute it is the hallmark of the prime
minister who struggles
to deliver bad news to the public a
similar point was made by
my boyfriend the member for leeds east
that there is a pattern here of the
government making the same mistakes over
and over again
and he also rightly highlighted the
continuing failure to provide
adequate financial support for those who
self-isolate a point that was also made
by my own
friend the member for stockport uh a
particularly epic point today
uh when the government report has
reached the news that the current
self-isolation policy has a low to
meeting
effectiveness and there are barriers to
self-isolation
this is a point we have been making
since the start of the pandemic and it
is about time the government listened to
us
and their own advisors and fixed it and
it would be remiss
of me not to highlight the fantastic
contribution from my
honourable friend and neighbour the
member for the city of chester he drew
attention
to how this announcement came out once
again via the media
and he also raised an important point
about the enhanced measures
a number of areas including our own
county of cheshire have been put into
this week
we have unfortunately seen a surge in
cases but there is
uh apparently no prospect of us getting
a rise in vaccines
i thank my honourable friend for giving
way speaking to my fellow healthcare
professionals
in my local hospital vaccination centre
weeks ago
many of them expressed their concerns
about the delta variants and a possible
impact
it could have on the local nhs and on
delaying
lockdown does my honourable friend agree
with me that the government needs to do
more
to prevent workplace burnout
by providing more workplace um support
to our fellow healthcare professionals
who have spent
the past 18 months um supporting the
government through their incompetency
an honourable friend for intervention
she's absolutely right we owe a great
debt to those in the nhs and those
who have also worked on the front line
during the past 18 months and of course
there was a very important select
committee report released last week
on the issue of burnout which i really
do hope the government uh
address uh because without the workforce
the nhs
is nothing but returning to um the
issues in cheshire
we haven't had an increase in vaccines
that the
surge in cases uh requires indeed it's
what
the government's own scientific advisors
say is the best way to deal with such a
an outbreak we have uh constituents
being sent far and wide to get their
first job and we've got fantastic
volunteers and nhs workers ready willing
and able to deliver those jobs
but we need the government to act match
that ambition by
increasing supply that will be where we
can make the most difference my mumble
friend also made a very important point
about
how we're now in the worst of all worlds
with new guidance issues at the same
time as these regulations came in
we're now advised not to meet indoors
again dividing people away from
hospitality sector which was just
opening up again
but without a penny more in financial
support for them and of course he also
mentioned
there are all the sectors that have been
affected by today's regulations that are
still not getting
any additional financial support to
recognize the change in policy that
we've seen
and on the issue of guidance and law i
do hope um
the minister opposite does look at the
household select committee report on the
constitution which was produced last
week
and they said that use of guidance has
in some instances undermined legal
certainty
by laying claim to legal requirements
that do not exist
they said the government does not have
and must not assume authority to mandate
public
behavior other than as required by law
and that the consequence of this has
been a lack of clarity on which rules
are legally enforceable
posing challenges for the police and
local governments potentially
undermining public compliance and
confidence so if living with cobid means
living with guidance rather than laws i
really do urge the government to read
that report before
they proceed down that road and i wonder
when the minister responds if he will be
able to clarify
whether the government are still making
decisions based on data
rather than dates i say that because
this was raised by a man with under
shadow secretary of state the prime
minister was pretty clear in his own
words
that the 19th of july was the terminus
date for restrictions
yet as we pointed out paragraph 7.4 of
the explanatory note accompanying these
regulations
states that the reason for the delay is
to enable more evidence to be gathered
on whether the government's test under
the roadmap can be met in light of the
delta variant
there will be a little point deputy
speaker in gathering this data if it
were not to be used to inform future
decisions
so that rather implies the 19th of july
might not be the end date
after all and as the right honourable
member for the forest of dean pointed
out
there is no mention in the explanation
at all the regulations about this
two-week
point at which things will be
reconsidered and of course we all hope
that the 19th of july is the end date
but we have been down the road of false
promises before many times
in the past 18 months and i don't think
it's unreasonable for us to be a little
bit skeptical of what about
what the prime minister says and and
what actually materializes given
his record today so any clarity the
minister can shed on this
and what the actual precise reason for
the delay is would be
much appreciated but of course this
delay
wasn't inevitable it didn't have to be
this way the delays to our unlocking
that we're debating this even were not
inevitable they were in fact totally
avoidable
the british public have been magnificent
throughout this crisis they followed the
rules
and they played their part but when they
see world leaders ignoring social
distancing at a barbecue but are told
the rules
cannot yet be relaxed for them when they
see thousands of people attending
football matches
but they're told they cannot attend
their own children's school sports day
they grow frustrated at what they see is
a lack of consistency from those who
make the rules
but that frustration grows into anger
when they see a prime minister who has
thrown it all away
by keeping the borders open and letting
the delta variant run wild
in the country as a result the delta
variant is now making up 96
of new infections that didn't happen by
accident and as the chief medical
officer said on monday
we would be lifting restrictions now if
it were not for the delta variant
all that good work all the benefits of
the vaccine blown because the prime
minister
was once again too slow just as he was
too slow with the first lockdown the
second lockdown
and the third i know the government will
say that they acted as soon as they
could on the information they had
but the explanation why they didn't act
soon on the delta variant has actually
changed in the last few days
we were initially told on multiple
occasions that the data did not support
putting india on the red list earlier
because positivity rates of the new
variant were three times higher to
pakistan
but now we are told the reason why it
wasn't put on earlier is because the
variance had not been identified
as one of interest or concern neither
explanation
stands up to scrutiny the only published
data on the indian variant does not show
a positivity rate three times as high
for pakistan
and the idea that action was taken
shortly before it was designated as a
variant concerned
does not explain why pakistan and
bangladesh were red listed weeks
earlier the only credible explanation i
can therefore find for treating india
differently is that the prime minister
didn't want to discover his trade visit
and photo opportunity with the indian
prime minister
so instead of excuses we should be
getting an apology because it is beyond
doubt
that it is the prime minister's
incompetence differing and vanity that
has cost this country dear
and that is the only reason that the
full unlocking of this country
is not going ahead next week having
heard today what
it via whatsapp uh on dominic cummings
what the prime minister thinks of the
health secretary
i wonder if the health secretary has at
any point in the last few weeks
had similar feelings towards the prime
minister if he has and that is something
that at least we can both agree on
thank you madam deputy speaker and at
the outset i would associate myself with
the remarks
of the shadow minister and respect of
our late colleague joe cox
as we stand at this dispatch box we can
see the coat of arms above
the opposition benches and i pay tribute
to her
and to all her work while she was in
this place and before
um madame deputy speaker i would much
rather i were not standing here today
seeking to urge and encourage colleagues
to have to vote for this motion i know
that colleagues would
wish that this was not necessary but i
regret
it is we have made huge progress
progress has been made possible by a
phenomenal vaccine
rollout program and that
the tribute for that goes to the
scientists who developed the vaccine
those who
procured it the nhs and all the
volunteers charities the military the
sun's jabs army everyone who's played
their part
in helping deliver this program
it's also that progress has also been
made possible by the incredible efforts
of of course the british people and by
the dedication
of everyone who works in our health and
care system and i know again the shadow
minister would join with me
in expressing our joint gratitude to all
of them
as the prime minister set out on monday
this vaccine remains our route out of
this pandemic
and with every day that goes by we are
better protected
by our vaccines but the delta variant
has made the race between virus and
vaccine
much tighter cases continue to grow
rapidly each week in the worst affected
areas the number of people being
admitted to hospital in england has also
begun to rise
and the numbers of people in icus is
also rising but madam deputy speaker
the vaccine remains our way out
data published this week shows that two
doses of the jab are just as effective
against hospital admission with the
delta variant
compared to the alpha variant and indeed
may even be more effective against the
delta variant
but it underlines madame deputy speaker
the importance of that second jab and
the need for more of us to have the
chance
to get its life-saving protection now my
right honourable friend the member for
north somerset put it far more
effectively than i dare say
i will be able to do he was absolutely
right
to highlight the crucial importance over
the next few weeks of getting those uh
second jabs particularly the astrazeneca
vaccine into people's arms he's right to
highlight that the fisa vaccine after
one jab
is highly effective but we need those
two jabs of the astrozenica vaccine to
provide that
level of protection it's important in
that context to remember that of course
the
azid vaccine is the workhorse of our
vaccination
programme over 30 million people
have now received their second jab and
in one month's time that number
could stand as high as 40 million and my
right honourable friend
the secretary of state highlighted in
his remarks a very important factor
in getting those second doses in
people's arms there are still 1.2
million
over 50s who've had the first dose
they're not
declining the vaccine they've had the
first days but they need the second dose
to provide that high level of protection
and similarly
there are 4.4 million of the over 40s
who again
need that second dose and with the delta
variant now making up nine in ten of the
cases across the uk
it's vital we bridge the gap and get
many more people that life-saving second
jab
this extra time will allow us to get
more needles into more arms
getting us the protection we need and
enabling us to see restrictions
fall away on the 19th and in that vein
i would remind colleagues the quote from
the prime minister on monday
where he was very clear that as things
stand and on the basis of the evidence i
can see
right now i'm confident we will not need
any more than four weeks
and that we won't need to go beyond july
the 19th
um turning madame deputy speaker to the
choice we fake
um very very briefly but it needs to be
very brief because i've only got three
minutes
you've just said that the prime minister
has given assurances there's another
four weeks but we've had this time and
time again why should the british people
believe the prime minister now
yeah well the short answer is the
british people do believe the prime
minister
now madame deputy speaker we face a
difficult choice
and my honourable friend the member for
bosworth set it out
extremely clearly it reflects that
underlying debate
about risk we know
and i am clear that we must learn to
live with this disease
and learn to live with it without the
sort of restrictions we have
seen we cannot eradicate it and i have
to say again
rather than relying on the views of the
member for leeds east i'm more inclined
to rely on the views of the member for
north somerset the right honourable
member for north somerset
who made that point very clear and being
very clear those who advocate a zero
covid
must realize that is impractical
unachievable and i consistently
do not subscribe to the logic of those
who argue
for that course but to get to the point
where we can
learn to live with this disease i'm sure
the house will agree an extra few weeks
is the price worth paying so i do urge
the house to support these regulations
today no one of course can fail to be
unsympathetic to those who will be
affected by this
delay like those couples who want to
start their married lives together
but have hacked in the past to change or
delay their plans it weighs on me
greatly as it will on all
honourable members and in this case i
was pleased that we could ease the
restrictions
on weddings equally i'm very mindful of
those whose livelihoods
will be affected by any delay in our
road map
but madam deputy speaker i urge the
house to support this motion it provides
a short-term delay
that significantly strengthens our
position for the longer
term um now my right honourable friend
the member for the
forest of dean raised a couple of
specific points which i will try and
answer
here and they relate to one another um
he mentioned paris 7.7 of the
explanatory memorandum
and his concern that the first review
date was on the 19th of july
i just clarified the first review date
is due by
monday the 19th of july and will be
in advance at that point that's illegal
end point
and i would anticipate an announcement
coming probably a week before that of
what that decision is and what that date
is i hope that gives him some
reassurance
about people having notice of what is
coming
um madame deputy speaker in closing i
wish to express my sincere thanks to all
those who've contributed today's
to today's debate i'm sorry there were
so few
on the opposition benches who chose to
take part but to those who did
and to those on this side of the house i
pay tribute to them for the sincerity
for the strength of feeling
and for the integrity that honourable
members have shown
i hope the house recognizes that i have
a deep-seated respect for all the views
i've heard
this afternoon honourable members all
want the same thing
which is to save lives and to see us
exit
these restrictions and return to
normality as soon as possible
difficult as it may be i urge honourable
members across this house
to vote for these net measures to give
ourselves that short extra time
to vaccinate more people crucially with
that second dose
and take us forward to a stronger more
confident future
that i know is just around the corner
that like all honourable members
i seek and we all seek and which i am
confident
this prime minister will take us to
madame deputy speaker i commend the
motion to the house
[Music]
the question is motion number two as on
the order paper as many as our of that
opinion say
i of the contrary no no
division clear the lobby
the order the question is number
motion number two as on the order paper
as many as our of that opinion say
i i of the country no no
tell us for the eyes maggie through and
maria caulfield
tell us for the nose steve baker and
jackie doyle price
lock the doors
order order
the ice to the right 461
the nose to the left 60. the eyes to the
right
461 the nose to the left
60. so the eyes have it the eyes have it
unlock
we now come to motion number three on
proceedings during the pandemic
minister to move formally
the question is motion number three as
on the order paper
as many as our of that opinion say i
of the country no division
clear the lobby
the question is motion number three as
on the order paper
as many as our of that opinion say i
of the country no tell us for the eyes
maria caulfield
and maggie through tell us for the nose
jackie doyle
price and steve baker
lock the doors
order order
the eyes to the right 588
the nose to the left 25 the eyes to the
right
588 the nose to the left
25 so the eyes have it the eyes have it
unlock
we now come to motion number four on
constitutional law
minister to move the question is as on
the order paper as many as our of that
opinion say
i the country no i think the eyes have
it the eyes have it
i beg to move that this house do now
adjourn the question is that this house
do now adjourn
giles wattling
thank you madam deputy speaker it's a
great pleasure to speak on this
important issue once again colleagues
may remember that i introduced a private
member's bill to regulate the use of
sonic anti-loitering devices in 2018
in my view unregulated these things can
be a menace
they are discriminatory painful to some
and can cause suffering to children
babies and animals i find amazing it's
amazing that some
in civilized britain either can even
consider them to be a useful adjunct to
policing
that is the stuff of totalitarian
regimes
we police by consent not by fear and
pain
i won't simply regurgitate my earlier
speech now but i'd like to remind the
house of some
key points sonic anti-loitering devices
also known
as mosquitoes or teenager repellents
target young people with a pulsing sound
my daughters tell me it's like a
prolonged beep
akin to tinnitus and some devices emit
ultrasound specifically to achieve this
effect
there are no no firm figures for how
many of these devices
there are nationally although
manufacturers claim to have sold
thousands
in 2010 the council of europe found that
this device was
degrading and discriminatory to
youngsters
and should be banned because it violates
legislation
prohibiting torture academics also
contest
that these devices contravene several
pieces of uk legislation regarding
anti-social behavior
and discrimination despite the
assertions of manufacturers
there are reports that people as old as
40 can hear these devices
and those who use them neglect their
impact on very young children babies and
animals as i have said
all of whom will struggle to communicate
any distress
caused likewise those who use these
devices
ignore the impact on those with
pre-existing conditions that make them
especially
sensitive such as autism many children
with these conditions cannot avoid
long-term exposure because
they might live next door to somebody
who has one of these devices or their
school might be close to one of these
devices
and they could equally struggle to
communicate any distress
now there's a lack of research on the
harm
caused by these devices especially the
effects of ultrasound
on the impact or the impact on those who
can't even hear them
40 of young people regularly come across
these devices
but 75 of young people said that they
would just
put up with the irritating noise and go
where they want when they want anyway
and do
what they want so these devices won't
stop those who want to commit
anti-social behavior necessarily but
they will harm
innocent young people in public spaces
now finally these these devices have
been banned on all council buildings in
sheffield kent edinburgh
and dublin on safety grounds
so as it stands madam deputy speaker i
still believe
that we don't know enough about these
devices to be confident that they are
indeed
safe and therefore we must control their
use
moreover these potentially dangerous
devices are not wholly successful in
preventing antisocial behavior
as they do not in to stop those
intending to do harm
from entering a certain public space if
they are so minded
and even if these devices were effective
against asb
at a certain location we would just be
moving criminals and their urge to cause
damage
somewhere else consequently i believe
these devices are not a solution for
antisocial behavior
they only succeed in causing distress to
those young people who cannot avoid them
but who have a right to use public
spaces where they are often located
now there are plenty of examples of
innocent young people feeling unable to
use
railway and bus stations shops schools
and spaces in their own town
centers all places where these devices
have been installed
and all places that young people are
entitled
to visit safely indeed there are reports
from a scottish survey
that 41 of young respondents
experienced health effects or discomfort
after encountering a device
and i highly doubt whether any of them
were engaged in any sort of anti-social
behavior at the time
according to those respondents
discomfort included headaches
migraines ear problems tinnitus
dizziness nausea
anxiety and or panic and we've not even
touched on the